Willkommen bei Kalender, Apps und Mädchenserien.
Am Damenbesuch. Also das einzige, was man Flash zu gut erhalten kann, ist, dass sie jetzt einfach weg sind.
Also die Flash-Entwickler, die ich kenne, die sind ja so hart gesortene Flash-Entwickler.
So, wovon wollen wir denn weitermachen?
Es gibt auch Freunde von mir, die haben es noch nicht verstanden, dass es iMessage gibt und die schreiben wir weiterhin Nachrichten über WhatsApp.
Was hast du denn für Freunde?
Die gibt es sogar für BlackBerry, WhatsApp.
WhatsApp gibt es sogar für Windows-Phone.
Kennst du private Menschen, die einen BlackBerry haben?
In Europa?
Nicht Bio2.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich habe die Leute auch rausgekickt und angezeigt. In Google+.
Ihr seid alle in der Video? Nein, ich nicht.
Ich guck gerade, wie viele Hörer wir mit der ganzen Debatte eingebüßt haben. Was hält sich den Grenzen? Es kommt das große Schweigen.
Jetzt können wir Schluss machen, oder?
Ja.
Haben wir eigentlich alles gesagt?
Ich denke auch, also die Themenliste ist durch, weil alle Themen, die uns so spontan einfallen würden, hat uns der Chat gerade verboten. Wie?
Wie haben wir das verboten?
Zensur?
Ja, also es ist ja nichts passiert. Zwei Wochen Stille. Nichts. Einfach nur Crickets.
Ich würde jetzt gern widersprechen, aber...
Dir fällt auch nichts ein.
Mir fällt auch nichts ein.
Wenn es.
War ja nichts los.
Ist auch ganz gut, wenn die Sendung mal nicht so lack ist.
Also heute kommt es mir...
Wir können uns ja erst mal mit Metathemen hier behelfen.
Hier in der Meta-Ebene.
Genau, in der Meta-Ebene.
Erstmal müssen wir uns noch für ein Geschenk von letzter Woche bedanken.
Was, Winnie?
Weiß ich irgendwas?
Ach, du meinst die Schucki?
Die haben wir in der Sendung total vergessen zu erwähnen.
Ja, die fiel Tim erst fünf Minuten nach Sendungsende ein, stand da da mit so einem riesengroßen Ding, mit einer viereinhalb Kilo Toblerone. Das ist wirklich absurd. Die hat zwölf Zacken, das heißt, ein Zacken wiegt irgendwie 375 Gramm. Ja, genau.
Nee, 400 irgendwas war das.
Nee, viereinhalb durch zwölf.
4,75 Gramm.
Nee, ich glaube, das waren 4,8 Kilo.
Schwer. Auf jeden Fall schwer.
Kannst du uns über Zahlen streiten?
Doch.
375. Voll lecker, voll der Zahnkiller, aber schmeckt immer wieder super.
Aber ist ein bisschen unpraktisch, die Größe. Man ist ja bei Toblerone eigentlich gewohnt, dass man sich so eine ganze Zacke auf einmal reinrammt.
Hab ich das zu Hause auch gemacht? Sah halt ein bisschen bekloppt aus.
Man muss schon mit einem riesengroßen Messer. Ich hab's ja nicht mal hier geschafft, richtig mit Manneskraft so eine Zacke abzubrechen. Das ging einfach nicht.
Mit Manneskraft hat's vielleicht geklappt.
Und hast du auch einen LFMF-Tweet abgesetzt? LM-Watt? Lattenshauen LFMF. Learn from my fail.
Ach so, ja, kann ich mich nicht merken.
Wo man solche Unfälle...
Ich bin halt ganz soweit für Twitter. Für dieses ganze Hashtaggen und Facebook-Pages und ah.
Aber für Facebook bist du auch zu alt.
Ja, sowieso.
Tja, ich hab auch überlegt, was man mal so migrieren könnte, aber mir ist nichts eingefallen.
Migrieren? Von wo denn?
Na zum Beispiel von da, wo wir jetzt sind.
Wo bist du?
Na ich bin bei Twitter. Ich bin total so der Twitter-Tweeter.
Sag keinen, Twitter ist doch nur Nachrichtendings.
Genau.
Sag keinen, Facebook ist doch WTF. Welcome to Facebook.
Kann man ja eigentlich, ich wollte ja mal rasch ein Bild in den Chat posten.
Ich kenne die Geschichte nicht.
Gibt es da noch eine Geschichte dazu?
Da habe ich doch schon mal erzählt, oder?
Da haben irgendwie Kids, die Facebook benutzen und die haben ihrem Daddy gesagt, dass er ja auch mal Facebook benutzen könnte und dann sind die halt da irgendwie so am chatten oder was auch immer. Ich war ja noch nie bei Facebook. Jedenfalls kommt der Dad dann auch irgendwie in diesen Chat rein.
Ja.
Nein.
Ich glaube nicht.
Dann kommt der Daddy in den Chat rein.
Ja und dann meinen die Kids WTF und dann meint der Vater was heißt WTF und die so Welcome to Facebook.
Ja, das war jetzt das erste Mal in der Metaebene, dass wieder laut gelacht wurde und geschrien und gejohlt und ich sag euch, es klingt echt besser, es klingt besser.
Wegen dem Styroporlagerdecke.
Das ist Basotect. Basotect ist wiederum teures Styropor.
Du meinst, die haben das so genannt, du hast es dreifach überzahlt und am Ende ist es halt auch so ein Schaumstoffzeug. Ich war mal eine Matratze, sowas ja.
Siehst du aber, die Mathe ist auch genauso laut wie früher. Wenn ich die Mathe trinke, dann schallt das immer noch.
Weil du deine durselige Rolls-Ball-Taste nicht drückst.
Die Flash-Taste geht nicht.
Besser, besser. An der Flash-Taste arbeite ich noch. Das wird alles wieder total toll. Ich musste ja erstmal die Metaebene an einer wichtigen Stelle, ich hatte ja einfach so viele Dangling Repairs, so viele Sachen, die einfach drohten auseinanderzufallen. Beziehungsweise Sachen, die mich schon immer gestört haben, wie zum Beispiel die Akustik.
Achso, wir sollten nur den Vorgang zugen machen, oder? Dann haben wir hier perfekte Akustik.
Ja, aber es ist schon interessant, dass man das jetzt schon nicht mehr so richtig merkt.
Aber kurze Frage, ich bin ja nicht so der Audio, also...
Ich erkläre dir jetzt auch noch, was das ist.
Ja, aber warum ist es so wichtig, dass man überhaupt gar keine Reflexion hat? Also, dass man das so ein bisschen weghaben will, verstehe ich ja, ist ja zu Hause auch unangenehm, wenn man irgendwie, wenn es so ein bisschen blöde klingt, hält. Aber warum muss man es so für so ein Studio so komplett weghaben?
Also, ich habe ja hier nicht keine Reflexion.
Ja, ja, ist schon klar, bist ja auch kein Studio.
Aber in so einem richtigen Tonstudio will man das halt deshalb haben, weil diese, wenn du Klänge aufnimmst für ein Hörspiel oder sonst irgendwas, für eine Audioproduktion, dann kommen ja diese ganzen Effekte, Hall und Rauch, also wie dieser Klang sich in einem Raum entwickelt, das kommt ja dann quasi später dazu.
Wenn die Person sich das anhört, meinst du?
Ja, was weiß ich, Angelo, du willst irgendwie das Pfeifen im Walde haben, ja, dann rechnest du halt den Wald da später drauf. Wie halt die Reflektion ist im Wald. Aber wenn du schon das Hall-Verhalten eines kleinen Raumes mit öfter Aufnahme hast, dann wird es immer wie ein kleiner Raum klingen, aber nicht nach einem Wald oder nach einer Kirche oder was auch immer du haben willst. Klar, wenn du es jetzt in ein Setting packst, wo Hall dann irgendwie übermäßig ist.
Wieso klingen wir nicht wie eine Kirche?
Ja, jetzt hätten wir halt die Möglichkeit, hier noch so einen Church-Modus zu aktivieren.
Church of Apple?
Ja, wenn wir mal verbindliche Aussagen treffen wollen, dann könnte man halt so eine Verbindlichkeitstaste hier noch auf der We-Boot einführen. Dann hätte man das halt so.
Die brauchen wir nicht so groß sein, weil die brauchen wir eh nie.
Die Tasse.
Die Verbindlichkeitstaste.
Und zum iPad 3 müssen wir euch sagen.
Ich glaube, dahin gibt es Tote.
Du meinst, dann hört meine Oma sogar auf.
Ich wollte aber jetzt keinen toten Raum machen, weil dann hätte ich hier wirklich alles vollballern müssen mit irgendwas. Aber ich musste einfach den größten Contributor zu HAL ausknocken. Und das war die Decke. Und dieses Basotec, das ist nur der Produktname von BASF. Die haben das halt irgendwie mal, ich glaube, das sind auch die einzigen, die es verkaufen. Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist das technisch ist das Melamin, Nein, das ist Styropor. Nein, das ist Melamin-Hartschaumstoff.
Basotec, ja.
Basotec. Und das ist halt so ein offenporiger Schaumstoff, der allerlei tolle Eigenschaften hat. Also das ist nicht nur toll im Bezug auf Akustik, sondern der ist auch gleich B1-Flammhemd. Das heißt, der brennt nicht. Er hat also gleich die höchste Brandschutzstufe, die man so haben will. Kannst halt in bestimmten Situationen, kannst du nur B1 nehmen. Das war auch immer unser Blinkenleitsproblem. Wenn wir mit unserem ganzen Plastik da irgendwie in die Häuser rein wollten, dann muss das halt alles B1 sein. Schwer und flammbar und es ist irgendwie formstabil und es ist irgendwie extrem farbecht und es lässt sich sehr gut schneiden, lässt sich sehr gut verarbeiten. Es ist noch flexibel und so. Und jetzt hab ich mir einfach hier 10 Quadratmeter an die Decke geballert und das hat jetzt hier wirklich so diesen frei torkelnden Hall, der halt vor allem genau dann sich breit macht, wenn es hier laut wird, jetzt hier wirklich diesen Effekt in die Schranken gewiesen. Ja und jetzt klingt es hier besser, finde ich.
Und kostet richtig Arschhörder Zeug.
Naja, ist nicht billig. Hier wird investiert. Hier soll die Zukunft stattfinden.
Deswegen ist hier mein Darth-Vader-Stimme jetzt ein bisschen anders. Das liegt nämlich eigentlich an der Decke.
Die sitzt wie im Original. Todesstern. Die hatten auch Büro Styropor an der Decke. Darum war der auch so teuer und es explodiert.
Ja, naja, willkommen bei dem Podcast, wo es eigentlich um Max gehen sollte.
Darum reden wir jetzt gleich über Google.
Aber es geht irgendwie nicht so richtig über Max, weil es ist einfach nichts passiert. Aber uns fällt schon noch was ein. Wir sind ja findig. Aber wir können ja erst mal so die Sachen abhaken, die sich sonst noch so zugetragen haben, Max.
Genau.
Ich war auf dem Google Developer Day hier in Berlin. Sollte ich jetzt vielleicht einen kleinen Disclaimer vorschieben?
Du hattest Feindkontakt, sagst du?
Achtung, Achtung!
Wie heimt ihr denn hier alles?
Wir werden ja sonst immer so gleich so beschimpft, wenn wir über Android irgendwas sagen, dass wir keine Ahnung haben.
Was ja auch stimmt. Ja, wir haben auch keine Ahnung. Wir können es ja gleich, also wir haben keine Ahnung von Android.
Das habe ich probiert nachzuholen.
Wir haben nicht alle 237 verschiedene Modelle, die auf dem Markt sind, selbst mehrere Wochen lang getestet. Shame on us. Und wie war es?
Also groß war es, riesengroß. Sie hatten das ICC gebucht, diese riesen Haupthalle. Ich war da schon...
Da passen verdammt viele Leute rein.
Über 2000 Leute waren's. Auf der Fahrt da hin konnte man in der S-Bahn so... Die gehen da hin, die gehen da hin. Die gehen garantiert auch da hin.
Also Nerds in Schwarz mit Rucksack?
Ja, nicht ganz so klischeehaft, aber im Groben und Ganzen schon. Also nicht so Kongress-Publikum, sondern schon eher so...
Noch schwerter.
Mit Maske.
Bisschen weniger Schwarz, so rum.
Ja, genau, ein bisschen weniger Schwarz. Schon Provinz-Nerd, sag ich jetzt mal.
Mit Maske?
Ne, mit Maske? Wieso mit Maske?
Weiß nicht. Ich war noch nie auf dem Google-Developer-Dev, vielleicht haben die ja alle Masken auf.
Vielleicht liegt da auch Stroh rum.
Ne, das garantiert nicht. Das Essen war ganz okay, bis aufs Mittagessen, das war ganz unerträglich. Es war irgendwie was, ich meine jetzt auch gerade so im Vergleich zu diesem iOS-Five-Day, also ich glaube, was man bei Google sagen muss, wer rein wollte, ist auch reingekommen. Also wenn du dich rechtzeitig vorher angemeldet hast, dann konntest du da bestimmt, dann bist du auch hingekommen. Ist nicht so wie bei Apple, wo er ausgesiebt worden ist oder sowas.
Die nehmen auch jeden bei Google.
Ja, die nehmen auch echt jeden. Und dann fand da eine große Kinot statt, wo irgendwie die Mitarbeiter von Google München in Lederhosen, weil sie sind ja in Deutschland und da muss man ja in Lederhosen auf die Bühne treten.
Was?
Na ja, Deutschland, Lederhosen, da denkst du auch ruhig in das Mal an.
Und so einen deutschen Nationalmannschaftstrikot.
Auf dem Nummer 5 HTML drauf stand. Und haben die ganze Zeit über high fived. So immer wenn sie sich bei der Kino gegenseitig einmalen.
Das ist ja genauso schlimm wie das Jubelgeklatsche bei Apple.
Exakt das hab ich auch gedacht. Ich hab gedacht, das was Apple mit seinen Kunden macht, das machen bei Google wird das mit den Entwicklern gemacht. Und dann gab es eine ganze Reihe Vorträge. Also es gab fünf, wie heißt das, wenn die parallel laufen, also es gab fünf Säle, in denen das stattfand.
Fünf Tracks.
Fünf Tracks, genau. Das eine zum Thema Android. Dann Chrome und HTML5. Alles was ich mir angeguckt hab, war zu dem Thema. Dann gab es noch Cloud, die Cloud mit App Engine und wie sie nicht alle heißen, hab ich mir dann komplett gespart, nachdem ich so aus einem der Vorträge gehört habe. Das war eine reine Verkaufsveranstaltung. Also, wir haben probiert zu erklären, warum der jetzt hier dafür dringend Geld ausgehen muss. Dann Google+. Da war ich auch selber überhaupt nicht drin. Da hab ich mich aber mit Trostesse Lix Thülmann unterhalten. Der meinte also, der erste Vortrag war Google plus und der plus eins Button. Und nun gibts zu diesem Button nicht so viel zu erklären, wie man sich vorstellen kann. Die haben im Wesentlichen gesagt, wartet noch, wir sind doch ganz am Anfang. Und dann hatten noch hier so die TU und die HU, die waren mit beteiligte Spielpartner, die durften ein bisschen mitmachen. Da waren auch irgendwelche Professoren so ein bisschen so standortpolitikmäßig. Die haben auch ein bisschen was. Das war dann der fünfte Track. Den hab ich.
Die TU und die HU.
Genau.
Beim Google Developer Day. Was, ich meine, was?
Was erlauben?
Ich meine, was ist da der Spin? Irgendwie waren die jetzt so Sponsoren?
Nee, ich nehme mal an, dass die eher umgekehrt, würde ich sagen, dafür, dass sozusagen, dass Google, also ich weiß nicht, ob Google den Geld gibt, die haben dann halt so ihre Android-Projekte und so, was sie da hatten, haben sie dann so ein bisschen vorgeführt und haben wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen um Studenten geworben und so was.
Die programmieren doch da ein Java, oder?
So war es doch, oder? An Unis?
Nee, ja, genau, aber auf Android halt.
Auf Android? Ja, das ist Java.
Na dann ist es doch halt die Mischung, wenn das halt sowieso die Studenten, naja, aber die Sprache an sich. Genau.
Ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt alle Studenten nur Java programmieren müssen.
Na, aber schon so ist es, ich glaube, wenn man ein Studium...
Schon so da deren Sprache auf Choices, nicht so, dass die dich da gleich irgendwie in X86 Assembler reinwerfen.
Also als ich da angefangen habe, als ich damals das bisschen studiert habe, am Anfang mussten wir da was lernen, das war Opal, eine funktionale Sprache, die sich einer der Profs ausgedacht hat und die, glaube ich, nur da gelehrt wurde, damit er seine Bücherpässe verkauft. Ansonsten war die weitgehend, ich glaube, es gibt schönere funktionale Sprachen als diese. Und danach war so Java. Und das wurde dir auch nicht beigebracht, sondern es war so...
Die waren irgendwie da und du wirst schon wissen, warum.
Und ich wollte mir echt mal Android 4 angucken. Ich probiere immer, so ein bisschen optimistisch zu sein, was Google angeht.
Ja, ich habe auch gehört, das ist total toll.
Genau, und ich habe hervorragende Kritiken, wirklich selbst Gruber sagt, dass es eventuell, nachdem er es gelesen hat, gut sein könnte. Gruber, ich meine, wenn der das sagt, dann muss es stimmen. Und darum wollte ich mir das mal so ein bisschen aus der Nähe angucken und hatte natürlich so ein bisschen still auf Hardware gehofft.
Die kommen ja immer alle nur dahin, damit sie sich ein Telefon schenken lassen, aber die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Offensichtlich sind die vorbei. Was es stattdessen gab, es gab so kleine, man hat so am Eingang so kleine Pokes bekommen. So diese oder Pox oder wie hießen die? Wie hießen die? In 19 war das glaube ich mal ganz hip, so diese kleinen Chips, die man für Geld kaufen konnte. Also man hat so Poks bekommen und da waren immer Symbole drauf und es gab fünf verschiedene Symbole. Und wenn du von jedem Symbol eins hattest, musstest du immer mit anderen tauschen.
Panini, Aufklebebildchen.
So was in der Richtung, genauso Sammelkälchen, musstest du mit anderen tauschen. Wenn du von allen fünf eins hattest, dann kriegst du es dann in den Chromebook geschenkt. Also es war dann so quasi die Tombola. Und also man kam da so rein in den Raum. Ich hab irgendwie da mit Möfiu den sofort getroffen, der erkennt mich auch mal schön an seinen Haaren. Der hat mir so, hey, was hast du für Chips? Ich so, keine Ahnung. Ja, dann hat er mir das kurzes Prinzip erklärt. Dann hab ich angefangen zu tauschen, hat innerhalb von dieser kleinen Runde, in der ich stand, hatte ich vier Farben zusammen. Ja, ja, und die Mangelware sind Chrome-Taps, also Chrome-Chips. Weil die hatten es offensichtlich begrenzt. Und es gab offensichtlich genauso viele Chrome-Chips, wie es Chromebooks gab. So, und dann hat sich das innerhalb von 20 Sekunden rumgesprochen, Chrome-Chips sind Mangelware. Und den Rest der Veranstaltungen haben die Leute immer nur noch, hey, hast du ein Chrome-Chip, hast du ein Chrome-Chip? Ist auch Geld geboten worden für diese Dinge. So 20 Euro war das höchst, was ich gehört habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob auch Geld geflossen ist. Also offensichtlich waren die der limitierte Faktor.
Hat irgendjemand mal einen gesehen, einen Chrome-Chip?
Ich hab am Ende welche gesehen, die ihre Chromebooks ausgepackt haben.
Aber du hast keins gekriegt?
Nein, ich hab keins gekriegt.
Wie viel waren das wohl so gefühlt?
Also ich hab nicht viele gesehen, aber ich hab auch nicht gesehen, wie sie verteilt worden sind. Aber ich glaube, ich schätz mal so, ja lass es 20 gewesen sein. Also ich würde sagen, viele waren es nicht. Was ich gerade zu erschreckend fand, also ich meine, okay, dass man keine Hardware geschenkt kriegt, ist jetzt muss man jetzt, ich kann ja nicht voraussetzen, aber ich dachte, dass man da wenigstens mal Geräte sieht, auf denen Android 4 läuft. Also das ist da irgendwie so ein, nein, es gab nicht einen.
Also es gibt doch jetzt angeblich eins in einem Laden zu kaufen. In England ungefähr.
In England, ja. Also zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es da schon zu kaufen, aber die hatten da so ein paar Demogeräte, also die Entwickler, die vorne irgendwas präsentiert hatten, die haben dann auch teilweise ihre Telefone schön in die Kamera gehalten, haben das dann auf diese riesen Projektoren gelegt. Aber ansonsten darüber hinaus habe ich nicht ein Gerät gesehen. Es gab so ein Google-TV, da konnte man sich irgendwo angucken. Davon hatten sie einen, so ein Demogerät da, aber so Android.
Oh, dass es gar keinen Hersteller mal davon gibt.
Doch Sony baut glaube ich noch welche.
Nee, Sony will er jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Die wollen auch nicht mehr?
Nein.
Ich hatte zwei Minuten den Controller in der Hand und verstand warum. Das war wirklich, das war dieses Google-TV, das ist echt nicht fertig. Also ich sage jetzt nicht, dass es schlicht ist, aber es ist einfach überhaupt nicht fertig. Das war so offensichtlich innerhalb kürzester Zeit. Man hat da einen Maus-Cursor, und man muss da mit dem Maus-Cursor...
Wie haben sie den Android-TV gezeigt, wenn es so...
Nein, auf der Bühne hatten sie Geräte?
Ah, dann doch.
Ja, ja, auf der Bühne. Aber eben nicht so, dass du mal selber rangehen konntest an so einen Teil. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt, ich glaube da war auch der Quellcode noch nicht veröffentlicht.
Ist das der jetzt mittlerweile?
Ja, ja, es ist rückportiert hier mit Synagran, Mod und so was. Und gibt es jetzt auch schon für offizielle, noch nicht unterstützte Geräte und so was. Aber was halt so mein Gedanke war, da sind 2000 Entwickler oder ein paar 100 Entwickler, die tatsächlich dann Apps entwickeln. Seit gestern gibt es dieses Telefon in England zu kaufen und die absolut größte Zahl der Entwickler da dürfte noch nie gesehen haben, wie ihre eigenen Apps unter Android 4 laufen. Und haben eigentlich auch keine Chance, das ernsthaft zu testen. Also da kommt ein neues System auf den Markt, mit komplett neuen User Interfaces, mit bestimmt vielen Fallstricken, wo irgendwas schiefgehen kann. Und du hast als Entwickler, außer diesem extrem lahmen Emulator, keine Chance, das zu testen.
War nicht mal eine Developer-Version für irgendein altes Telefon.
Ich glaube, ich hab's jetzt mitbekommen. Das erste, was ich mir da angeguckt hab, war der Vortrag Excellence in the Android User Experience. So, das dachte ich so, okay, das wird jetzt so der Vortrag, wo sie hingehen und wo sie mal erklären, so Android 4.0, diesmal werden wir das ernst, User Interface, so sieht's aus, das ist die Schrift, so müsst ihr Padding machen, das dürft ihr machen, das dürft ihr auf keinen Fall machen, erklären, wieso die gesamte Philosophie dahinter ist. Weiß der Teufel was ist, kling die ganze Zeit nur um diese Action Bar. Also Action Bar. Die haben jetzt in Android 4, haben sie die Menüs abgeschafft oder probieren die jetzt, oder natürlich nicht abgeschafft, also machen die jetzt, bauen die jetzt um, weil es war ja immer dieser dämliche Menü Button da, den die User offensichtlich nicht gefunden haben, weil so ein versteckter Button auf einem Interface und du weißt nie, ob ein Web App irgendwas bringt oder nicht.
Menü Button? Einer von diesen vier Hardware-Buttons?
Genau, einer von diesen Hardware-Buttons.
Den hat keiner gefunden.
Naja, was heißt nicht gefunden? Ich glaube aber, du vergisst einfach, weißt du, das du beim iPhone hast, das Schöne, alle User Interface-Elemente, die da sind, siehst du auch sofort. Also darum gibt es, glaube ich, auch nicht so wahnsinnig viele Gesten. Bei Apple. Oder es ist zumindest für jede Geste immer noch irgendwo ein Button vorhanden. Und da hast du halt diesen Menü Button und in einigen Programmen bringt er was, in anderen Programmen bringt er nichts. Und dann muss man ja auch erst mal drauf kommen, dass man diesen Menü Button klicken muss. Das ist ja so wie der Rechtsklick bei der Maus. Da muss man ja auch erst mal drauf kommen, dass da eventuell noch ein paar Optionen drin stecken könnten. Ist ja auch nicht so total intuitiv. Darum haben sie jetzt da diese Action Bar eingeführt. Das ist halt so eine Leiste oben und oben und Bildschirmrand.
Das ist ja eh schon so ein Bar.
Na, so diese Status-Leiste gerade schon. Na jetzt sozusagen für die App, wo die App so ihre wichtigsten Aktionen drin hat. Die haben dann ausführlich erklärt und die kann unter Umständen auch gesplittet werden und auf einem Tablet sieht sie so aus und auf dem Telefon sieht sie so aus und dann passiert das. Und die haben wirklich, das war die ganze, also dreiviertel Stunde, genau dreiviertel Stunde haben die immer gedauert. Die dreiviertel Stunde hat ja nur über diese Action-Bar geredet. Am Anfang mal kurz, dass es zwei verschiedene Seams gibt. Und das fand ich ehrlich gesagt auch relativ schwach, dass so dieses nicht erklärt, wann welches Seam einzusetzen ist. Also bei Apple gibt es immer dieses wir haben da die Möglichkeit und da die Möglichkeit, die Variante ist für folgende Fälle gedacht, die Variante ist für jene Fälle gedacht. Und bei Android ist es so, wir haben ein dunkles Seam und ein helles Seam. Genau, beide Arten. Und anstatt mal so ein, vielleicht steht das ja irgendwo noch in den Anleitungen drin, weiss weiß ich, ich hab's ja nicht gelesen, dass da irgendwie noch das Handbuch steht, aber zum Thema User Experience hatte ich mir wirklich was komplett anderes erwartet. Und was ganz gut war, kommen wir mal zwischendurch zu den positiven Sachen, die leider in viel zu kleinen Räumen stattgefunden haben, sodass ich da mal raus musste. Die ganzen Chrome-Sachen hatte ich das Gefühl, dass die alle ganz gut waren. Also so Bleeding Age, HTML5, wo dann so jede neue API in Chrome durchgesprochen wurde und mal demonstriert wurde und gezeigt wurde, was man damit am besten anstellen soll und so schön fluffiges Tempo gemacht. Das war echt ganz gut. So kann man sich bestimmt auch alles aus dem Netz holen, aber das nochmal so präsentiert zu kriegen, ist ja schon echt eine Menge wert. Und mein persönliches Highlight des Tages oder Lowlight oder ich weiß nicht, wie man es nennen soll, war der Vortrag What's New and Important in Android. Da soll es darum gehen, was neu und wichtig ist bei Android. Und das war einer der schlechtesten Vorträge, die ich jemals gesehen habe.
Warum?
Weil der Typ, der das gemacht hat, der stellte sich hin und es fing damit an, dass er so über, also auch ein bisschen was, hey, wir haben bei Android, es gibt ein neues User Interface. Und dann fängt er an, liest irgendwo so ein Zitat vor, so was auf seiner Slide drauf stand.
Slides vorlesen, ganz kurz.
Ja, liest das vor und sagt, ich weiß ja nicht, was das bedeuten soll. Also wenn es nach mir geht, ein gutes User Interface sieht so aus. Blendet einen Screenshot von einem Terminal ein mit einem Bash. Also wenn es nach mir geht, würde jedes User Interface so aussehen. Das ist ein gutes User Interface. Aber ich muss das ja, das haben sie mir ja gesagt, dass ich das vorlesen soll. Das hat er zweimal betont innerhalb dieses Vortrags, dann über diesen neuen Fond, Roboto, auch irgendwie ein Zitat vorgelesen. Also ich hab da keine Ahnung von, dann mach den Vortrag nicht, dann halt ihn einfach nicht, dann mach was anderes. Selbst wenn du User Interface nicht mag, mach diesen Vortrag nicht.
Was war jetzt neu und was war jetzt wichtig?
Das neue User Interface war wichtig, klar, dann haben sie ja dieses ganze NFC.
Das neue User Interface, was sie dir aber nicht erklären wollten.
Außer, wie er ein bisschen was über die Action bei erzählt. Tatsächlich, nochmal. Dann dieses NFC-Zeugs, das du jetzt zwei Geräte dicht aneinander halten kannst und dann irgendwie Actions her und her schieben kannst.
Echt?
Das betonen die da? Ich glaub, die wollen halt in diesen ganzen NFC-Bereich rein.
Schön gesagt, die wollen in den NFC-Bereich rein. Aber für sinnvoll halte ich das ja nicht.
Ich glaube schon, dass sich das, also so Mobile Payment, ich glaube, das wird ein ganz großes Ding werden.
Oh ja, keine Frage.
Aber damit kriegste keinen Entwickler geködert.
Ob NFC da die Antwort ist, da bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher.
Gut, das wird sich zeigen. Aber auf jeden Fall, Sie wollen offensichtlich einen NFC und jetzt haben Sie einen Anwendungsfall dafür und dann kannst du irgendwie zwei Telefone aneinander halten. Und wenn du vorher in den Settings, den und den und den, das war auch immer schön, dann muss ich nur in den Settings das und das und das und das aktivieren und schon brauch ich nur zwei Geräte aneinander halten und in der Actionbar das tippen und schon kann... Eine, zwei Stunden später. Dann haben Sie noch so was quasi so ein... Also technisch ist das ja alles wirklich ganz cool, was Sie zum Beispiel haben, ist so ein direkter Wi-Fi-Kontaktmodus. Das war Telefone offensichtlich ohne WLAN, direkt Verbindung zueinander aufnehmen kann und dann hier irgendwie Daten hin und her schicken können, mit hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Ohne WLAN?
Ohne eine WLAN-Basistation zu brauchen. Also Sie machen sich selber ein WLAN-Metz. Dabei ist Ihnen das Telefon zweimal abgestürzt. Bei der Demo. Das war fertiges Software. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie für den... Nee, für den Teil hatten Sie keinen NFC. Für den Teil, das war einfach nur reines WLAN. Also das ist so, ja, wir müssen hier in den Discovery-Modus, also das war auch nochmal durch die Einstellung durchgegangen hier und jetzt aktiviere ich bei beiden Telefonen den Discovery-Modus und dann passiert das und dann ist das Telefon abgestürzt und dann war das Telefon irgendwann wieder da. Sehr schöne Neustartanimation, muss ich mal sagen. Und dann hat er es nochmal probiert, dann ist irgendwie nochmal das Telefon abgestürzt und irgendwann hat es dann geklappt und dann hat er ein Bild hin und her geschickt und war offensichtlich auch nicht gerade begeistert davon, wie das geklappt hat. Dann, was war denn noch so schönes? Achso, ja, und dann kam, das fand ich echt, am Ende ging es dann ein bisschen darum, Fragen zu stellen und so was, konnten die Leute Fragen stellen. Und zwar ein wichtiges neues Feature in Android 4 ist auch, dass man kann sehen, wie viele Daten jede App verbraucht hat, also hast du Statistiken und kannst so für einen Tag verteilt sehen, wie viele Megabyte und so weiter und so fort. Und dann wird da vorgeschlagen, dass du ja immer auch hier Settings anbringen sollst, um sozusagen den Datenkonsum ein bisschen zu reduzieren, falls der User das hat. Und falls dem User das nicht in den Kram passt, dann hat er die Möglichkeit deiner App den Netzwerk Traffic abzuschalten, also den 3G Traffic. Und danach kannst du keine Internetverbindungen mehr aufnehmen. Und dann kam irgendwie am Ende, kam dann so ein, also in dieser Frage- und Antwortzeit kam dann schon einer auf und er klang echt ein bisschen bedrückt, so Ja, ich hab ja so ein Spiel für Android entwickelt und verkaufen konnte ich nicht, weil irgendwie die Verkaufszahlen nicht so doll sind. Und darum probiere ich mich über Werbung zu finanzieren und erzählte mir gerade, dass ihr gerade den User jetzt eine Funktion angeboten habt, damit sie mir die Werbung abschalten können. Und du kriegst es mit wie der vorne auf der Bühne so dasteht, so, oh, das haben wir nicht bedacht. Und sich dann rausredete mit, ja, aber das ist ja genauso, als ob bisher der User immer im Flugmodus dein Spiel gespielt hätte.
Nur, dass es per App ist.
Nur, dass es per App abschaltbar ist und dass jede Wette, wenn sich Android 4.0 irgendwann mal in drei Jahren halbwegs durchgesetzt hat und auf allen Telefonen verfügbar ist, dass sofort in der Computer-Bild ein langer Artikel drinne steht, haha, so Angry Birds kostlos spielen ohne Werbung. Also ich meine, das wird ja so quasi so diese Geheimtipps-Scheiße werden. Jede Wette. Was dazu führen wird, auch jede Wette, dass Spiele-Entwickler und App-Entwickler, die auf Werbeeinnahmen angewiesen sind, zuerst darauf achten, ob sie überhaupt eine Internetverbindung haben.
Alle erstmal nach Hause telefonieren.
Alle erstmal nach Hause telefonieren. Wenn sie keine Netzwerkverbindung haben, sich einfach weigern zu starten. Was dazu führen wird, dass man in Flugzeugen keine Android-Spiele mehr spielen kann.
Weil warum sollte man im Flugzeug auch Spiele spielen?
Wir fliegen heute noch ohne Netz.
Da kann man sich einfach auf die Elan für 20 Euro dazugehen. Wie man es früher gemacht hat.
Wobei mir an der Stelle auch mal aufgefallen ist, dass das, was man bei Android nicht bereit ist, was die User nicht bereit sind, zu zahlen an Geld an die Entwickler, das zahlen sie wahrscheinlich mit Netzwerk-Treffik drauf. Weil diese ganzen Apps, die sich dann über Werbung finanzieren, die Werbung muss ja auch irgendwann runtergeladen werden.
Ja gut, ob das jetzt so entscheidend ist in den Dataplans heutzutage, das wage ich jetzt mal zu zweifeln. Es sei denn, wenn da die ganze Zeit irgendwelche HD-Movies nachgeladen werden.
Naja, ich glaube, das Problem ist vielmehr von dem Geld, was du zwar mehr zahlst, also wenn du über deine 200 Megabyte hinaus bist, oder welchen Vertrag du auch immer hast, und dann irgendwie für die nächsten 10 Megabyte 30 Euro zahlst, davon hättest du dir das App für ein Leben lang kaufen können. Das ist uns zwar verursacht.
Das mag sein, ja.
Das ist ja alles nicht so schön, was du erzählst.
Was waren denn positive Aspekte?
Was positive Aspekte waren?
Ich meine, da waren ja nun ganz viele Developer, die vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt so einen Apple-Bias hatten wie du. Hattest du den Eindruck, dass die Digitalen zufrieden sind?
Also ich würde sagen, dass über die Hälfte der dort vorhandenen Telefone iPhones waren. Ist jetzt so eine Schätzung, kann auch. Aber es ist nicht wie bei einer Apple-Veranstaltung, wo du 100% hast. Oder auch nicht nah dran. Sondern es sind sehr, sehr viele iPhone-Benutzer dabei, die auf diese Veranstaltung mit ihrem iPhone gehen.
Und vielleicht auch iOS-Developer, die sich Android einfach mal als die nächste Plattform, die sie vielleicht auch noch unterstützen, anfangen.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht Leute, die für Android entwickeln, aber dann doch lieber ein iPhone haben. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Oder einfach nur Web-Entwickler, die ein iPhone haben und sich jetzt über den neuesten HTML-Scheiß schlau machen wollten. Kann ja auch sein. Das fand ich eher so.
Ja und nicht mal aber du reine Android-Die-Hards-Setzer. Ich...
also ich hab...
Was mit denen nicht geredet?
Du stößt ja auch so... Ich probier ran zu gehen und dann ist das... Ist das was? Nee, ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab mich mit ein paar... Wie gesagt, mit Möffe habe ich mich ein bisschen unterhalten, der gerade nach diesem What's New and Important in Android wirklich schimpfend wie ein Rorschpatz da raus ist und meinte so, er wollte ja Android 4 sehen, bevor er sich entscheidet, ob er ein iPhone sich kauft oder hier so ein Android-Gerät. Und er ist glücklich, dass er das gesehen hat, weil jetzt ist seine Entscheidung klar. Ich glaube, er hat sich danach noch ein bisschen beruhigt und hat... Ist jetzt vielleicht doch ganz glücklich mit Android, aber das war...
Das war...
Also wie gesagt, das Chrome-Zeug fand ich, das bisschen, was ich gesehen hab, war leider etwas zu wenig, fand ich ziemlich gut, aber dieses Android-Zeugs, diese Vorträge, die ich dazu gesehen habe, die waren... Die waren so... Man hat das Gefühl, dass die Leute, die da die Vorträge gehalten waren, nicht hinter dem Produkt stehen. Also gerade jetzt bei diesem einen Typen, der da die ganze Zeit... Klar, das sollte alles locker wirken und extrem entspannt und weiß der Teufel was und haha, guck mal, ich bin Nerds und mir geht es doch eigentlich gar nicht so um dieses... um die User. Aber bei der entsprechenden Apple-Veranstaltung und der Unterschied ist echt frappierend. Bei Apple, bei diesem iOS 5 Tech Talk, zum Beispiel gab es einen Vortrag darüber, wie man eine iOS-App dazu bringt, schnell zu starten. Und das dauert eine dreiviertel Stunde, der Vortrag, oder wie lange haben wir den gedauert? Und die erste Viertelstunde ging es nur darum, warum ist das überhaupt wichtig? User wollen das so, der erste Eindruck zählt. Du willst ein 5-Star-Rating, du willst das und das, du willst, dass deine App schön ist, du willst, dass deine User die App lieben. Also du entwickelst für die User. Und bei diesem Android-Vortrag war auch nur als Witz, ja wir wissen ja alle, dass User sind ja die Leute, die Fehler machen, weil man schreibt eine App oder man schreibt ein Programm und kompiliert und hat null Fehler und dann setze ich einen User ran und schon hat es Fehler. User machen Fehler.
Wie das hat jetzt jemand auf der Bühne gesagt.
Das hat jemand auf der Bühne gesagt.
Stimmt ja auch.
Ja klar. Wie gesagt, ich finde das auch okay.
Der User findet halt die Bugs, die man selber nicht gefunden hat, weil man weiß ja, wie man sein Programm verdient.
Natürlich, klar. Ich finde das auch als Spruch lustig. Ich finde auch gut, dass es Leute gibt. Aber der Mindset geht in die falsche Richtung. Wenn du auf so einer Bühne stehst und du willst an den User ran und du willst Dinger verkaufen, du willst Apps verkaufen, dann musst du da anders rangehen.
It's not for users.
Und das ist, das dann so auch rüber zu bringen und zu sagen, User Interfaces sind eigentlich scheißegal. Und das steckte wirklich diverse Male drin. Also es wurde natürlich an den Slide-Stand was anderes, aber er hat gesagt, dass User Interfaces eigentlich wurscht sind. Und Hauptsache, es kompiliert. Und das fand ich so...
Tja, das ist ein fortwährendes Drama.
Und ich hab halt, es fehlte, also aus dieser iOS 5 Tech Talk wiederum jetzt im Vergleich bin ich rausgekommen und war für mich so, die meinen das mit diesen Post PC Ernst. Die wollen jetzt iCloud großbringen, die wollen Dokumente, die du zwischen iPhone und iPad und den ganzen Geräten sinken kannst, die vernünftig gebacked-up sind. Das ist deren Richtung. Da wollen die ganz groß hin. Das ist das, wo Apple hin will. Ich bin bei Google rausgekommen. Und ich konnte keine Richtung sehen. Du hast einen Haufen kleiner Verbesserungen. Ja, einige davon sind sicherlich auch sehr schön und tolle Sachen. Aber es ist nicht so, dass ich das Gefühl... Ich hab das Gefühl, da haben so ein paar Teams vor sich hin entwickelt. Und haben etwas gebaut, was jetzt irgendwie ganz benutzbar ist, aber wo so eine Linie fehlt, eine klare. Und mein Eindruck war, dass auch den anwesenden Android-Entwicklern diese Linie durchaus fehlt. Und dass die nicht ganz zufrieden sind mit dem, was da läuft. Also die hätten zum Beispiel gern gehört, dass wahrscheinlich der Market jetzt mal richtig angegangen wird und darauf geachtet wird, dass da sich auch Apps verkaufen. Und dergleichen kam nichts. Stattdessen kam Face Unlock, das nicht funktioniert hat auf der Bühne.
Ja, tja, was soll man dazu noch sagen? Ich weiß nicht, Dennis, fällt dir da irgendwas zu ein?
Android ist das Linux unter dem Telefon.
Ja, das ist eine geradezu technische Aussage. Naja, ich meine, es ist Linux. Ich meine, was willst du damit sagen?
Na, dass es halt auch so ein Frickel-Ding ist.
Tja, weiß nicht. Schauen wir mal. Also ich sehe wenig, was mich irgendwie beeindruckt gerade. Vielleicht erinnert sich das ja noch, aber ich finde, das ist irgendwie alles unexciting. Ja, warum ist ein Huckel eigentlich nicht da? Wir wissen es gar nicht, ne?
Doch, das ist krank. Ich hab noch gefragt vorher, wer ist krank.
Wie gefragt vorher? Jetzt gerade eben vorhin? Er ist krank.
Das hat man schon gemerkt, er hat schon getwittert, dass er irgendwie Blade Runner-Scheiße findet.
Ja, ich hab auch schon gleich zurückgetwittert, weil er ja krank ist. Das muss bestimmt an den Medikamenten liegen, die er genommen hat, die ihn bestimmt runterdrücken. Dann hat man ja schon manchmal so einen anderen Mindset und findet alles doof und so.
Nach dem Tweet wusste er wahrscheinlich, dass wir ihn rund machen würden.
Er hat sich nicht mehr hergetraut. Die Blade Runner Fanboys standen schon vor seiner Haustür und haben demonstriert.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ob mit so einer Einstellung überhaupt das hier noch das Richtige ist für ihn.
Ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher. Und Brasil fand er auch nicht toll.
Zu dritt geht das ja auch ganz gut.
Aber ich kann mir die mal angucken. Ich hab die Beine noch nicht gesehen.
Schlecht der für Leute an? Die sagen, ich wär schon wieder zu leise, hab ich mein Mikro schon wieder nicht richtig ausgerichtet? Ja, also ich hab mal nachgefragt, ja. Und das ist jetzt nicht direkt von ihm, sondern von seinem Lebenspartnerin.
Seinem Lebenspartnerin.
Ich wollte das neutral ausdrücken, ja, ist mir nicht gelogen. Also naja, ist ganz schön 80s und langatmig, passiert ja auch oft nichts, außer die obergeile Kulisse gezeigt wird. Und dann die cheesy Fahrstuhlmusik bei der Liebesszene. Kann man sich schon mal anschauen, aber irgendwie ist andere... ist man andere Erzählweise gewöhnt.
Ist ihm nicht schnell genug? Ah, diese Manga-Kirchen.
Also, naja, Manga, sowas guckt er auch nicht. Klar ist er ein bisschen so 80s. Und klar ist er auch ein bisschen langsam.
Der ist aus den 80s.
Ja, und der ist auch ein bisschen langsam. Aber ich denke mal auch, ich glaube, der wäre, wenn er nicht so ist, wie er ist, wie soll man das jetzt genau ausdrücken, aber dann wäre er ja nicht zum Cool-Film geworden. Wenn es so ein Standard-80s-Film gewesen wäre, dann würde jetzt gar keiner mehr gucken. Also ich würde sagen, also Highlander ist kein Cool-Film. Oder doch? Scheiße. Highlander? Gibt's da Leute, die denken, dass das ein Cool-Film ist? Nee, aber so Blade Runner ist schon, der hat so viele Quotes, die man da irgendwie sich gemerkt hat aus diesem Movie, die einfach mal rock'n'roll sind. Also das ist schon cool.
Ich meine, Blade Runner hat einfach eine klasse Story. Die ist schon mal cool. Das ganze Setting ist ja auch top aktuell, immer noch.
Ja, und das wird es wahrscheinlich auch eines Tages irgendwann mal sein.
Und der ist einfach so irre, ist auch so krass blutig. Ich hab mich gelitten.
Blutig?
Ja, der Rutger Hauer, der blutet am Schluss so pervers so rum, so vor sich hin.
Nee.
Ja, für mich ist das so.
Ah ja stimmt, du bist ja so ein Blutophobiker.
Jaja, ich bin ein bisschen.
Hast du den Final Cut schon gesehen?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Es gibt so viele Cuts, da weiß man es nicht. Es gab zu 25 Jahre Blade Runner, hatten wir glaube ich auch schon an der Sendung, gab es noch mal einen neuen Cut, der heißt The Final Cut, der ist noch mal wie ein paar Minuten länger. Und in der Szene ist er hier...
Ist das nicht identisch mit dem Directors Cut?
Nee, nee, nee.
Richtig, richtig, wirklich alles neu, alles noch mal richtig schick gemacht und digital, tralala, diese Pyramide noch mal richtig ordentlich und so. Und angeblich haben sie die... Also ich kann schon hören, dass ich es irgendwo gelesen habe. Angeblich haben sie diese Pyramide von diesem Haus da, diese... Wie heißt die Corporation? Tyrell Corporation haben sie diese Pyramide noch mal aus dem Lager geholt und haben die noch mal gefilmt. Angeblich, bin mir noch nicht so sicher. Vielleicht haben sie einfach nur 3D aufgehöpscht. Keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls...
Echt, die hatten sie noch?
Ja, angeblich.
30 Jahre alte Kulisse?
25. Hatte bestimmt irgendein Fan zuhause und die haben den angerufen und gesagt, ey yo, wir brauchen ihn noch mal. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht haben sie auch irgendwie einen angesetzt und der musste den noch mal machen. Nee, glaub ich nicht. Jedenfalls die Szene, wo der Nexus 6, wie heißt der eigentlich, der Rotgehauer, hatte der auch einen Namen? Betty? Wie hieß der?
Du kannst Fragen fragen.
Egal, jedenfalls als er seinen Maker tötet, also in den früheren Cuts siehst du ganz kurz, wie er halt irgendwie so seinen Kopf so ein bisschen zerdrückt und wie seine Daumen so auf dem Auge liegen und dann wird er irgendwie so weggeblendet und dann siehst du, hörst du nur noch die schlimmen Geräusche und, ähm... Roy, also doch Betty, sag ich ja.
Ja, den Nachnamen hat er.
Und, ähm, in den Directors, also in dem Final Cut jetzt, dann siehst du aber wirklich das Blut fließen, also dann, äh...
Du meinst, richtig war es für mich.
Ja, also da musst du dann heulen.
Hier muss ich mir anschauen. Den findest du dann am geilsten. Was sind deine Lieblingscharakter? In deinsem Film?
Alle.
Davon abgesehen.
Also den Typen ganz am Anfang, den... Tell me something about your mother. Den Nexus, den mag ich am wenigsten, weil der kommt ja auch nicht so wirklich lange vor. Aber alle anderen sind eigentlich ziemlich cool. Also Roy Betty ja sowieso, denn hier die... Die Frau, die halt in den Glasscheiben irgendwie... In die Glasscheiben stürzt, ja. Ja, die ist auch einfach nur cool. Da meint er ja auch zu ihrem Englischen, was sagt er? Sie könnte... also er sagt ja, er könnte sich... Sie könnte sich ja nicht vorstellen, was Männer tun würden, um einen Blick von ihr zu erhaschen. Und sie ist ja mehr oder weniger stripper. Und sie antwortet dann ganz locker, naja, doch. Sie weiß ja genau, was wäre er dafür tun, um so einen Blick zu erhaschen. Übrigens auch eine großartige Szene.
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Wir sind gleich fertig mit Blade Runner. Meinen Dating muss ich auch noch sagen. Ich bin natürlich auch eine Frau.
Ist ja klar. Ich war jetzt nur ein Beispiel. Die sind alle cool.
Die sind alle furchtbar cool gezeichnet. Aber wo ich immer wieder total wegfliege, das ist die Pris.
Ja, die ist halt auch super.
Mit ihrem schwarzen... Wo sie sich hinsetzt.
Und sich hinsetzt wie alle anderen androiden Puppen, die dieser Puppen-Maker da irgendwie macht und dann plötzlich da loslegt.
Okay Leute, wir nerven euch nicht länger mit alten Filmen.
Doch, aber eine Sache muss ich Ihnen auch kurz mal ansprechen. Auch wenn ich es vielleicht schon mal gemacht hab. Hier weiß ich nicht. Oder in einem Movie-Podcast, den ich mal mit dem Macher gemacht habe. Jedenfalls, was mir aufgefallen ist bei Blade Runner, ganz am Anfang, da kennst du die Szene mit, mit, wie heißt die, die Tyrell-Angestellte? Rachel. Genau. Und dann ist doch die Eule da, ne? Und dann fragt er, ob die Eule, is it expensive? Und sie sagt so, very. Also das heißt, Die ist auch gekommen. Nee, genau, is it artificial? Of course it is. Is it expensive? Very. Also das heißt, die künstliche Eule, sagt sie, ist sehr, sehr teuer. So, später gibt es aber eine Szene, da fragt hier der Blade Runner, fragt diese Zora, oder wie sie heißt, ob die Schlange echt ist, die sie hätte. Und da meinte sie, ne, wenn sie eine echte Schlange sich leisten könnte, dann müsste sie hier nicht arbeiten. Das heißt, künstliche Schlangen sind billiger als echte. Warum ist dann aber die erste Eule, wenn die künstlich ist, warum ist die dann wiederum teuer?
Vielleicht ist das so ein Deluxe-Edition und Eulen sind generell schwieriger.
Du meinst also, nach künstlichen Sachen sind billig, dann kommen die echten Sachen, die sind ein bisschen teurer, aber die ganz künstlichen Sachen, die sind wieder so richtig teuer. Das heißt, die echte Schlange liegt so dazwischen.
Gute Frage. Naja, die Kernsummary von diesem Film ist ja, wir leben in einer Zukunft, in der Menschen geklont werden können und auch geklont werden.
Und Tiere auch.
Die Tyrell Corporation ist diejenige, die diese Teile irgendwie an den Start bringt. Tiere eben auch.
Wir bringen Tiere an den Start.
Und der Blade Runner, Harrison Ford, ist halt jemand, der schon früher in seinem Leben, und das ist quasi der Spin in dem Film, dass er dann wieder herangezogen wird für diese Tätigkeit, Klone jagt, die halt irgendwie durchgedreht sind und eine Gefahr für die Öffentlichkeit darstellen.
Weil diese Roboter dürfen nicht auf der Erde sein, weil da gab es mal einen Aufstand und seitdem haben Roboter Verbot auf der Erde.
Da haben sie halt irgendwie auf den anderen Planeten geschafft, aber vier haben es irgendwie zurück geschafft.
Sechs.
Modell Nexus 6 haben es wieder zurück geschafft. Richtig, das Modell Nexus 6. Und dann ist es halt schon mal sehr schwierig, die überhaupt von Menschen zu unterscheiden. Und das können halt nicht viele gut, und er kann es, und deswegen wird er engagiert. Und dann entspinn sich halt so diese Geschichte, wie er diese sechs halt jagt. Das ist einfach so ein...
Ja, jagen sind dann nur noch vier. Zwei sind ja schon bei irgendeinem Überfall auf Tyrell Corporation gekillt worden. Ich hab den erst letztens wieder geguckt.
Ja, okay, ich hab den nicht mehr im Detail so, nicht mehr in jedem Detail drin. Aber was ich schön finde daran ist, und an der Stelle ist es halt einfach auch nicht so eine reine Action-Film. Ich meine heutzutage, dieses Thema, da denkst du dir so, naja, es gibt so tausend Filme, die Aliens irgendwie kommen oder die Klone kommen, und dann kommt ein Typ und ballert sie alle ab. Aber es geht überhaupt gar nicht um dieses Rumballern. Es geht eigentlich um was ganz anderes. Es geht um diese ganze Metadiskussion, so, ja, wann bin ich ein Ich? Wann bin ich ein echtes Wesen? Habe ich irgendwie ein Bewusstsein? Und ab wann habe ich eine Existenz zu leben? Weil sie haben halt in diese Nexus 6 eine Zeitbegrenzung eingebaut. Sie wissen zwar, dass sie eine haben, aber sie wissen nicht, wie lange. Quasi als Sicherheitsabschalt.
Sie haben sie ja nicht eingebaut, sondern die ist halt da. Sie haben es nicht besser hingekriegt. Nach vier Jahren sterben die halt langsam. Deswegen kommen die auf die Erde. Die von ihrem Maker wollen Lebensverlängerung. Deswegen gehen sie zu ihm und sagen, wir wollen länger leben. Und der sagt, wir können nicht. Weil egal, was wir probiert haben, wir haben euch nicht länger hingekriegt als vier Jahre. Dann befallen euch Viren oder sonst die und dann müssen sie halt irgendwie sterben. Also eigentlich wollen die Nexo 6 Anruine nichts weiter als länger leben.
Nummer 5 lebt.
Genau. Aber wir sollten wieder mehr über Max reden.
Warum gibt es eigentlich noch keine Thunderbolt of Firewei Adapter? Das nervt mich.
Ja, es gibt noch überhaupt keine Thunderbolt Adapter.
Also es gibt ja dieses 1000 Euro, 800 glaube ich nur, dieses große Gerät, wo man auch gleich das Status-Display mitbekommt.
Habe ich ein Büro, ist geil.
Gibt es nicht irgendwie diesen kleinen Kasten von irgendeiner Firma für 300, 400 Euro, wo irgendwie alle Ausgänge...
angekündigt.
Ach so, gibt es nicht, nee.
Also von irgendeinem Hersteller, die haben angekündigt...
Glaub mir, das ist voll cool.
Ich habe das Display im Büro.
Ja, zu Hause.
Du stellst dir das Display hin. Ich will zu Hause kein Display.
Du machst dir die Tastatur direkt ans Display ran und dann brauchst du nur noch deinen Rechner hinstellen, Thunderbolt reinstecken, Strom reinstecken, fertig. Und dann hast du deine Arbeitsstation.
Ich hab das im Büro. Das ist alles super. Es ist total toll.
Wie Kodos von dir zu Hause?
Doch, aber auf der Couch.
Auf deinem Air?
Ja, klar.
Wenn du da den Simulator aufmachst, in Retina-Modus ist es schon zusammen skaliert, oder?
Retina-Modus geht nicht mehr so richtig. Das ist, aber es ist, das passt. Das ist okay, ich kann darauf gut entwickeln. Ich will kein Schreibtisch zu Hause stehen haben, ich will keinen Bildschirm zu Hause stehen haben, aber vielleicht keinen Bock.
Was machst du denn in der Freizeit? Ohne Schreibtisch und Bildschirm?
Ich setze mich halt auf die Couch. Wenn ich mal kode. Ich kode jetzt auch nicht mehr, doch eigentlich gar nicht so wenig, aber ich finde das absolut akzeptabel und absolut gut, das hoffen. Also ich da jetzt hier irgendwo einen Schreibtisch mir ins Wohnzimmer stelle.
Ich würde mir trotzdem auch gerne mal was in dieses Thunderbolt reinstecken, weil das war einer der Hauptgründe, warum ich mir überhaupt jetzt dieses Laptop geholt habe. Und was ist passiert seitdem es... Es gibt nichts.
Also du willst ja was reinstecken, aber du weißt noch nicht was und geben tut es auch nichts.
Na ich weiß ziemlich genau was ich will. Und damit habe ich fest gerechnet, ich will Gigabit Ethernet haben.
Also wenn man nach... Ja, damit ich Audio habe.
Ehrlich gesagt, dieses Display finde ich total scheiße. Weil da das Kabel fest dran ist.
Achso, ja.
Was einfach eine bestimmte Länge hat.
Und der Kalender ist scheiße.
Was ich machen müsste, wäre mir das Kabel verlängern und das sehe ich einfach nie ein. Also ich meine das finde ich wirklich minderwertig. Warum ist da ein Kabel dran?
Ein festes Kabel. Weil die keinen Bock hatten, dass man hinter dem Monitor rumschrauben muss, wie man es bei allen anderen Monitoren machen muss. Wenn das Kabel wieder irgendwie nicht... Also kennst du es nicht, die ganzen Monitore, DVI oder früher VGR, du musst immer dahinter greifen, dann sind die mal so schräg dran oder so nah am Gehäuse, dass du diese gerendelten Schrauben, dass du die nicht so richtig greifen kannst, um irgendwie dran zu drehen. Also das heißt, die Kabel sitzen locker drin und fallen raus oder sie sind festgeschraubt und wenn du sie mal rausmachst, kommst du nicht richtig ran.
Die haben ja auch ein Thunderbolt-Kabel. Das ist ja ein schickender Mal das Thunderbolt-Kabel. Das geht ja wohl rein.
Ja, und ich meine, wenn das jetzt wirklich das Argument wäre, dann kann ich nur sagen, erfindet doch jetzt nicht bitte einen neuen Standard mit einem neuen Stecker und das Erste, was einem auffällt, ist, dass das Kabel von alleine rausfällt.
Also ich finde, Apple könnte mal ein neues Ethernet-Stecker-Dings erfinden.
Haben sie doch, WLAN.
Naja, das haben sie ja tatsächlich mit dem Thunderbolt auch getan, in gewisser Hinsicht.
Sozusagen.
Das ist ja eigentlich so ein Generic-Adapter für alles. Nur, es kommt halt nichts. Und ich frage mich natürlich ernsthaft, warum kommt nichts, obwohl so viel als angekündigt wurde? Da gibt es dann verschiedene Erklärungsmodelle. Entweder, die versuchen gerade alle was zu bauen, aber es funktioniert nicht richtig. Der Chip ist scheiße und irgendwie, wenn man nicht irgendwie Apple ist und mit Intel schon seit zwei Jahren an diesem Standard entgegenkommt, dann trägt man es nicht auf die Reihe.
Glaube ich nicht. Ich kann mir genau den gleichen Chip nehmen, der in diesem Display drin ist. Und den gibt es ja wohl. Oder meinst du, Apple hat gesagt, hier Intel macht man nur für uns und sonst niemand?
Aber diese Balken-Ankündigung, die ist jetzt wie lange her? Vier Monate?
Ja, vielleicht, keine Ahnung, vielleicht sind die halt auch nicht so gut.
Balken?
Ja, Balken, die sind nicht so gut, das stimmt.
Balken, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, was sie...
Schlecht sind. Aber...
Nein, ich meine Balken gehören definitiv zu den besseren Accessory-Herstellern. Das ist jetzt nicht irgendeine Bude, sondern die machen schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren. Auch im Apple-Bereich wissen sie im Wesentlichen, was sie tun. Das heißt nicht, dass jetzt jedes Produkt von denen zu meiner vollsten Zufriedenheit performt hat, aber die haben immer wieder coole Sachen. Ich denke, die sind sich der Implikation einer Ankündigung grundsätzlich schon mal im Klaren.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich hab bisher noch kein Balkenprodukt in der Hand gehalten, was nicht scheiße gewesen wäre. Wirklich? Ich hatte mal einen Router von denen, der war ganz unerträglicher Scheiß. Und ich hatte mal ein iPad-Cover, so eine iPad-Hülle, das Ding war so scheiße, also ich hab's wieder zurückgeschickt, dass sowieso, es stank nach so billigem Teppich, Auslegteppich-Scheiß. Also das Material hat keine 20 Cent gekostet haben.
Also jetzt wo du es sagst, fällt mir ein, dass der USB-Switch, den ich hatte, auch scheiße war, der USB-Hub. Aber ich weiß, dass da auch gute Sachen dabei sind. Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht über Balken reden. Ich wundere mich nur, was los ist bei Thunderbolt.
Fremdherstellern.
Nichts passiert. Ja, ich meine, es kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass sie jetzt irgendwie die Zukunftsschiffstelle machen und alles was rauskommt sind irgendwie zwei Festplattengehäuser und ein Display.
Jetzt gibt es sie ja auch erstmal seit einem dreiviertel Jahr, oder?
Nee, es gibt schon. Also hier die Ankündigung, die ich habe, wenn man so Thunderbolt Firewire Adapter bei Google eingibt, das ist das Zweite, was man findet, eine Ankündigung von Sonnet für ein Thunderbolt auf Firewire Adapter, die ist vom April. Und das ist, ich habe keine Ahnung, was die da treibt. Ich kann mir ja vorstellen, dass die so den Markt testen, also mal gucken, wie viel Feedback, erstmal sich auf irgendeine Messe stellen, sagen ja ja, wir bauen das. Und wenn sich nicht 200 Leute melden und sagen, ja, ich will das ganz dringend haben, oder genug Vorbestellungen da sind, dann wird es halt wieder abgeblasen. Oder niedriger Priorities.
Ich gucke gerade mal bei Sonnet. Mittlerweile haben sie eine Thunderbolt-Seite auf ihrer Webseite.
Aber alles, was ich hier sehe, auf der hoffen, Produkte sind die, die ich kaufen kann.
Sind irgendwie Express-Cards. Die kann man auch nicht mal kaufen.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also vielleicht gibt es ja von dem Zeug ein bisschen was.
Ja, weil sie haben ja auch so einen Ethernet-Adapter angekündigt und den gibt es ja auch. Den haben sie dann auch irgendwann zurückgezogen.
Den haben sie explizit zurückgezogen?
Ja, den hatten sie angekündigt und seitdem habe ich nie wieder was davon gesehen. Und auch auf ihrer Webseite haben sie irgendwie hier ein Festplattengehäuse, ein Mini-Server, den sie X-Server nennen. Was ist das? Wreckmount One-U-System mit PCIe für Thunderbolt-Technologien mit Mac Mini. Also ein 19 Zoll-Gehäuse, wo du ein Mac Mini reinschiebst und wo du dann irgendwie PCI-Slots hast über Thunderbolt. Ah ja, das ist ja auch pfiffig.
Und immer noch kein Firewire, oder?
Ähm, ich sehe nichts davon. Ich hab jetzt auch so einen Adapter, dann halt einen Express-Card-Slot, oben irgendwie Thunderbolt.
Ich glaub, das ist einfach billig, Express-Card-Slot, da brauchst du wahrscheinlich nur so ein Ding reinschmeißen, und es geht, und dann haben sie Juhu geschrien. Vielleicht haben die da andere Prä- Also ich bin ja so verzweifelt, dass ich kurz davor bin, mir hier so einen Express-Card-Slot-Adapter zu kaufen, der hier am 14. Dezember kommen soll, und da dann irgendwie so einen Express-Card Firewire 800 oder 400 Adapter reinzustecken. Du kannst hier so eine Box kaufen, die du per Thunderbolt anschließen kannst, und da hast du einen Express-Card-Slot so extern rumstehen, und da kannst du dann wieder eine Firewire-Karte reinstecken. Und das ist bestimmt eine solide Lösung, die ohne Probleme funktioniert. Und jetzt hat jemand auf Kickstarter so einen Dog fürs MacBook Air angekündigt, wurde auch mit Thunderbolt, da hast du USB-Ausgänge und Display-Port, und kannst noch irgendwie, weißte Teufel was, und alles Mögliche und alles. Suche ich dir gleich raus und kein Firewire! Vier USB-Anschlüsse, aber kein Firewire.
Wofür brauche ich vier USB-Anschlüsse? Das hast du auch schon gesehen, so ein Monster-Teil.
Ja, und man ist verzweifelt, wenn man auf ein Kickstarter-Projekt hofft. Und nicht mal das hat's. Ich weiß nicht, warum die das alle nicht einbauen.
Was ist denn das für ein Dog?
Ja, es sieht scheiße aus. Wie heißt das? Landing Zone?
Ja, das heißt, du steckst da links und rechts irgendwie alle möglichen Stecker rein, ja? Ist ja gewagt. Na ja gut, weil man weiß, dass Thunderbolt genau das komplett ersetzt, ne? Ich hab keinen Flash install, sagt er mir. Ich kann mir das Video nicht angucken. Da kriegt man Geld nicht.
Achso, das ist dann so der Dockro-Aso, damit kann man es in die Breite schieben. Das ist dann sozusagen... Sieht aber auch so aus, als ob man da so, wenn man ein bisschen zu viel Kraft drauf anwendet, dass dann das MacBook auseinanderbrechen könnte, oder?
Das ist alles scheiße. Also wir können ja mal hier zu der wünsch dir was Abteilung kommen.
Thunderbolt auf Feuerwehradapter.
Ja, ich meine, die Frage ist ja auch überhaupt, wie soll es weitergehen?
Mit dem Mac.
Mit welchem? Mit dem Mac Pro?
Mit dem Mac im Allgemeinen.
Geschickte Überleitung?
Na wieso, also Macbooks und Airs und Minis und iMacs wird es ja wohl...
Ich hoffe, den Mac Pro wird es auch weiterhin geben.
Meinst du?
Ja, ich meine, es gibt ja auf jeden Fall noch eine Zielgruppe, die den unbedingt braucht.
Wofür denn?
Na Leute, die ihre Software so schnell, wie es irgendwie geht, ablaufen lassen wollen. Da gibt es durchaus Bedarf.
Echt? Ich weiß nicht, ob das so viele sind.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es viele sind. Ich habe gesagt, dass es diese Zielgruppe gibt und die ist bereit, ein Premium zu zahlen.
Die können sich auch einen iMac kaufen?
Nee, ein iMac ist halt nicht so schnell.
So viel langsamer ist es jetzt auch nicht, oder?
Was ist denn da drin? Du kannst einfach an den Mac Pro tonnenweise RAM reinschieben.
Das geht einfach mal am iMac schon mal gar nicht. Und es gibt einfach eine Menge Anwendungen. Die brauchen einfach tonnenweise RAM.
Na ja, wie viel geht da rein in so einen 16 oder 32?
In den iMac. Mal gucken, wo aktuell die Ausbaustufe endet.
Also ich muss jetzt zu meiner Überraschung sagen, dass seitdem ich so einen MacBook Air habe, also seitdem ich SSD habe, hat sich mein Bedarf an RAM plötzlich erledigt. Vorher war das immer so, dass ich gerne 8 GB... Wie viel hast du da drin? 8 oder 4? 8. Also ich hätte, wenn ich jetzt einen MacBook Pro geholt hätte, hätte ich es garantiert auch mit 8 geholt. Klar, mehr ist immer besser. Aber ich vermisse es nicht. Also das ist...
Man guckt ja da aber auch nicht mehr hin. Also man merkt ja gar nicht, wie viel der da gerade von braucht und wie viel nicht.
Ja, aber das ist halt so... Ich hatte vorher einen MacBook Pro, als da noch eine drehende Scheibe drin war, also eine richtige Festplatte drin war, da ist mir ständig aufgefallen, dass er zu wenig RAM hat. Und ich brauch mehr RAM, mehr RAM, mehr RAM. Und dann hab ich da eine SSD reingepackt. Und dann hat sich auch mein RAM-Problem erledigt. Das find ich total krass.
Also... Aber RAM kostet auch nix mehr.
Ja, aber hier geht halt nicht mehr rein, als die 4 GB, die drin sind.
Und insofern...
Ansonsten klar, wenn er... Ich hab jetzt noch nicht gesehen, irgendwie 35 Euro für 8 GB.
Bei dir gehen bestimmt auch mehr rein irgendwann mal. Apple spezifiziert ja immer nur, was gerade möglich ist und nicht was gehen kann.
So, also der Top of the Line iMac hat 4 Cores, 3,7 mit 3,4 GHz, i7, Hubbard's Redding, tralala. Und... Wo steht RAM? 32 GB. 32 GB kannst du da reinschrauben.
Das ist doch auch ganz ordentlich. Was geht denn so in so ein... Offiziell in so ein Mac Pro hier rein? Ist das das teuerste Modell?
Naja, der hat 12 Core. Der hat schon mal so 12 Core, das ist auch schon mal eine Ansage.
64 GB RAM.
12 zu 4 ist schon mal...
Der kleinste davon, ja?
Nö, so der jetzt, das rechts unten Modell. 2,93, aber sind dann halt auch diese... Xeon Prozessoren. Also das sind dann auch die schnellen Prozessoren. Die ziehen halt auch ordentlich Strom und so. Die haben auch Verbrauchskosten. Aber das Ding will halt irgendwie atmen. Das ist halt zweimal 6 Core. Und RAM max sich halt aus bei 96 GB. Schon nochmal eine andere Abteilung.
Ach krass, da gibt es ja noch das Cinema Display für zu kaufen. Für den Mac Pro.
Das ist 30 Zoll.
Das ist 27 Zoll.
Na die haben ja auch keinen Thunderbolt und so.
Aber ich meine ansonsten gibt es doch das Display gar nicht mehr.
So, du kannst da Karten reinstecken. Das geht halt auch nicht beim iMac.
Naja, aber es geht theoretisch. Also dann würden sie sicherlich kommen, wenn dann wirklich der Leidensdruck da ist.
Ja, theoretisch geht es, dass du mit Thunderbolt ein externes PCIe hast, aber das ist dann halt auch nicht so schnell wie die schnellstmögliche PCIe-Variante, die du in so Mac Pro dann ausfahren kannst. Du kannst da halt auch wirklich den Bus im maximalen Betriebsmodus fahren und nicht nur in dem Modus, den Thunderbolt jetzt über das Kabel überträgt. Also du hast da immer noch andere Durchsätze und du hast vor allem Platz und du hast irgendwie ein ordentliches Gehäuse drum herum und das wird gekühlt und wenn du da viele Platten hast und wenn du viel RAM hast und wenn du eben viel Power hast, brauchst du halt einfach den Platz. Dann kannst du natürlich iMacs hinstellen, aber es ist einfach not the same.
Also das ist für die Leute, die ein Mac Pro, dass es eine Zielgruppe gibt, für die das das perfekte Gerät ist, und die mit einem iMac wesentlich unglücklicher werden, glaube ich dir sofort, gar keine Frage. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob Apple diese Zielgruppe für ausreichend groß hält.
Ja und du kannst dann auch den Rechner irgendwie woanders hinstellen.
Finde ich auch cool.
Wie viel wiegt der irgendwie? 25 Kilo oder sowas? Achso, hinstellen meinst du einmal unter den Tisch stellen und dann steht er da?
Ja irgendwo, ja oder nebenan.
Durch die Wand bohren und dann?
Ja, wo er vor sich hin lüften kann und du legst dann halt einfach dein Displaykabel dann entsprechend lang und dann war's das. Ich meine, was soll man immer direkt neben seinem Rechner sitzen? Ist ja auch wie auch Quatsch. Ich glaube, dem wird's auf jeden Fall erstmal noch eine Weile geben und mit dem nächsten verfügbaren neuen Top of the Line Prozessor wird's halt einen neuen Mac Pro geben. Wie lange das jetzt noch weiter geht, weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, aber der geht jetzt nicht so schnell weg. Ja, ansonsten, was wird schon passieren? Also werden halt die neuen MacBook Pros im Air Design kommen oder vielleicht wird einfach die Air-Linie noch um ein 15 Zoll Modell ergänzt und die Pros bleiben noch eine Weile noch mal ein Jahr dick und...
Also entweder kommt, also wie auch immer, da kommt ein MacBook Pro eher. Also ob es irgendwie ein 15 Zoll Air ist oder ein MacBook Pro mit einem Air. Also so oder so. Es wird vorne ein Stück schmaler.
Ja, definitiv.
Und das Laufwerk fliegt raus. Genau, das reicht ja fast schon.
Genau.
Muss nicht langsam... Was sind eigentlich mit dem 13 Zoll MacBook Pro? Das gibt's ja noch, oder? Dass die sich so eine Parallelhaltung von zwei 13 Zoll Geräten erlauben, das wundert mich ja.
Das wird eine Übergangsphase.
Naja, das ist halt mit Laufwerk, ne?
Ja, kann man sich auch schön extern dazu kaufen.
Und mit Ethernet drin.
Der Laufwerk will doch niemand mehr.
Ja, aber Ethernet wollen Leute.
Ich hab gestern zum ersten Mal, glaube ich, mein Laufwerk benutzt. Ich hab gestern zum ersten Mal das DVD-Laufwerk benutzt.
Wofür?
Um das DVD zu gucken. Wobei wir haben die gerippt und dann auf die Linux-Dinge geschoben und von da geschaut.
Ja, aber ich meine so Ethernet. Ich hatte gerade neulich so eine Diskussion mit jemandem, der meinte, soll ich auf den Mac wechseln und so, dann meinte ich, es gibt Ernst, Gepro. Und dann war so, hat Ethernet, war definitiv ein Killer-Argument, weil wenn du so als Selbstständiger in irgendwelche Firmen reingeladet kommst und du musst da jetzt mal Collectivity haben, dann ist das halt so, über WLAN kriegst du vielleicht Ethernet.
Nee, WLAN geht nicht für externe, weil Blah unser Sicherheitsbeauftragter, ne, können wir nicht machen und eigene Station dürfen wir nicht. Ja, dann kriegst du halt so ein WLAN oder VLAN, also ein VLAN, oder hast du da irgendwie so Besuchernetz, wie auch immer.
Ein Freund von mir, der arbeitet in einer Firma, der einen Namen ich jetzt nicht nennen will. Der hat ein MacBook, weil er iPhone-Entwicklung macht, beruflich, und darum hat er ein MacBook, aber MacBooks dürfen, Apple-Rechner dürfen nicht ans LAN, weil Apple-Rechner sind ja bekanntermaßen total unsicher, und da gibt ja massenhaft Viren dafür und so, und das darf auf gar keinen Fall ran. Das heißt, er musste sich, es läuft jetzt so, dass er sich über den, dass es unten ein Café gibt, wo er sich ins WLAN reinbucht, vom Büro aus, und es kostet irgendwie pro Stunde 5 Euro. Aber das zahlt er, das ist kein Problem, Hauptsache er ist nicht im LAN drin. Und das hat irgendwie ein Vierteljahr gedauert, bis er sich das zurecht organisiert hatte, dass das so halbleger ist.
Der Mac-Cola, ja.
Der konnte ein Vierteljahr nicht arbeiten. Nein, Macs dürfen wir nicht ansetzen.
Versager. Selbst wenn es so ist, hätten sie mir einen VLAN machen können. Selbst wenn es so ist, hätten sie mir einen VLAN da irgendwie legen können, dass er sein eigenes Netz da kriegt. Sollen sie mal bei Wikipedia, das können die ja, bestimmt sollen sie mal VLAN eintippen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das können, wahrscheinlich sind die Seiten eh gesperrt. Wegen zu vielem Viren und so. Aber ich weiß nicht, also ich hab jetzt im Büro, das ist, wobei, das ist sehr lustig, ich hab jetzt an dem Thunderbolt-Display, ist jetzt Ethernet dran und das ist schick, weil das ist toll schnell und so und seitdem hab ich Ethernet und yeah, alles super und viel schneller als vorher und neulich ist das WLAN ausgefallen und ich hatte plötzlich kein Netz mehr. Nee, das steckt hier dran, bis dann irgendjemand aufgefallen, dass das Kabel von meinem von meinem tollen Thunderbolt-Display hinten im Patch, also im Router, im falschen Port drin steckte und gar nicht konnektiert war.
Die ganze Zeit nicht.
Die ganze Zeit nicht. Also zumindest zwei, drei Wochen.
Immer nur das Gefühl, dass es schneller ist.
Ganz am Anfang hatte ich, also am Anfang hatte ich einen am anderen Platz, wir haben zwischendurch umgeräumt, dann hab ich so mal so, hey gucken und auch so ein paar Tests gemacht und gesehen, dass es wirklich schneller geht und danach hab ich mich halt drauf verlassen, ja wird schon schnell sein und ich war die ganze Zeit über WLAN drin und hab's nicht mehr gemerkt. Also so halbwegs geht das. Achso, aber zuhause, apropos WLAN, hab ich mir jetzt so ein Powerlan Zeug geholt. Kennt ihr das?
Nein.
Wo hast du das geholt?
Was das über Strom?
Genau, über Strom.
Powerlan heißt das?
Ich weiß nicht wie der, ich glaub das ist so eine der Markenbegriffe dafür. Von wem hab ich das? Ich kann doch mal gucken, von welchem Hersteller ich mir das geholt habe.
Ach du nennst das so.
Ich glaub das ist auch so ein halboffizieller Begriff dafür. Also wo auf jeden Fall die Steckdose, die Stromleitung genutzt wird als Kabel für...
Powerline nennt man das normalerweise.
Genau, ich glaub so gesagt.
Powerline, ich hab Powerlan verschrieben.
Egal, auf jeden Fall. Also mein WLAN in meiner Wohnung war so scheiße und das hat nicht durch die ganze Wohnung gereicht, weil ich weiß nicht, was in den Wänden drin ist, aber irgendwie scheint da Signal nicht durchzukommen. Und immer wenn ich mal einen HD-Film streamen wollte, dann hat der gebuffert ohne Ende, weil das ging halt auch über WLAN dran. Hab jetzt keine Geschwindigkeitstests gemacht, weil mir aufgefallen ist, dass ich nicht mal die Hardware habe, um Geschwindigkeitstests ernsthaft durchzuführen.
Ich hab's dir ja gleich gesagt, als du eingezogen bist.
Zieh Kabel.
Und du so, nein, WLAN reicht völlig. 21. Jahrhundert, geh mir vom Leib.
Jetzt hab ich halt Powerlan, hab überhaupt keine Kabel geschmissen. Und ich will keine Kabel schmeißen, ich hab da keinen Bock drauf.
Aber was kommt denn da raus für eine Performance?
Wie gesagt, ich konnte es nicht messen, weil ich hab einen PC, der noch Ethernet hat, ich hab einen Apple TV, der Ethernet hat und ich hab einen Router und das war's dann auch. Und damit kann man jetzt nicht vernünftige Geschwindigkeitsmessungen machen. Auf jeden Fall ruckelt es nicht mehr, wenn ich mir einen HD-Film angucke. Offiziell sind das 200 MBit.
Dann hast du auch mal zwei Stockwerke drüber bei den Nachbarn auch mal reingesteckt und geguckt, ob du da auch noch deine Pakete mit sniffen kannst?
Nee, hab ich nicht. Es steht auf der Verpackung irgendwas von Verschlüsselung drauf.
Die ist bestimmt total gut. Ja, weil du vor allem keine Keys einstellst, sondern nur reinsteckst.
Die scheinen beim ersten Konnektieren ausgehandelt zu werden.
Beim ersten?
Also wenn du reinsteckst das Ding, dann hab ich das Gefühl, weil ich hab, als ich das nämlich das erste Mal ausprobiert habe, da hab ich die irgendwie mit etwas größerem zeitlichen Abstand reingesteckt und dann hat der auch nicht mehr geblinkt und dann hat er auch keine Verbindung mehr hergekriegt. Also ich vermute mal, dass der einfach, dass der eine Handshake-Phase hat, wenn du die beiden Geräte reinsteckst.
Das klingt ja total sicher. Bin mir sicher, dass du diese Handshake-Phase danach nie wieder angestoßen bekommst.
Bestimmt nicht, auch nicht nur Stromausfall oder sowas.
Nee, nee. Dann gucken die anderen halt mit.
Gucken die anderen halt mit? Nee, aber es ist okay, schnell. Es ist furchtbar, dass die Dinger so unglaublich viele LEDs haben, weil gerade wenn man so im Wohnzimmer sitzt und mal ja abends beim Fernsehen das Licht ausmacht, da unten so eine blöde Netzwerk...
Blau?
Nee, gelb. Oder Orangengelb, was jetzt nicht unbedingt besser ist. So eine blinkende Orangengelb.
Was hast du denn für eine Marke?
Warte mal, ich guck jetzt mal, was ich mir da geholt habe.
Belkin?
Äh, nee, mit so einer Frau drauf. Mit so einer Frau, die so aussieht, als würde sie sich an ihren Powerline Adapter kuscheln.
Devolo.
Ja genau, was hab ich hier von denen geholt?
Da ist eine Frau drauf.
Ja, das könnte durchaus sein. Devolo könnte... Wo sind denn hier meine letzten Bestellungen? Offene Bestellungen nicht?
Ich muss sagen, ein Netzwerkprodukt. So ein richtiges Geek-Tool. Weißt du, wo eine Frau drauf ist?
Nee, ich hab nicht das Mini, sondern ich hab das Power, weil da kommt...
Wieso, hast du jetzt ein Haus oder warum brauchst du sowas?
Nee, ich hab eine Wohnung. Und da reicht das WLAN halt nicht. Ist das WLAN nicht gut genug.
Was hast du zu Hause für eine Station?
Zwei Fritzboxen.
Kaufte dir noch mal eine ordentliche Apple-Station.
Ja, dann ist sie nach einem halben Jahr kaputt und dann kauf ich mir eine neue.
Wieso ist die kaputt?
Das liegt nicht an der Station, weil ich hab die Station an der alten Wohnung gehabt, da hab ich perfekten Empfang gehabt.
Fritzboxen, oh, gib mich starten.
Und bei der jetzt bei der neuen Wohnung...
Also ich hab ja zufällig gestern den anderen Tech-Artikel über die Airport Extreme Station gelesen, die diesen Sommer rauskam, diese fünfte Generation.
Welchen Artikel?
Von anderen Tech über die Airport Extreme.
Gibt's da einen?
Da gibt's einen, so 20 Seiten lang auseinandergenommen mit Zoom-Fotos bis auf drei. Und die erklären, die haben da halt in den MacBook Pros, die raus kamen, sind halt, wie heißt die, Broadcom-Ships drin. Und in dieser Airport Extreme, das, was die letzte, fünfte Generation Änderungen diesen Sommer hat, ist eigentlich, die haben genau das gleiche Motherboard. Aber die WLAN-Karte, die drinsteckt, die ist ja so ein Mini-PCI-Slot damit drauf, die ist halt jetzt auch von Broadcom, die war vorher wahrscheinlich von einer anderen Bude. Und dadurch machen die da sozusagen von Broadcom zu Broadcom so einen Spezialmodus, wenn man einen guten Empfang hat. Das heißt dadurch, dass es noch schneller als der Standard eigentlich erlaubt, weil die sich ja erlauben können. Und Apple hat sich gedacht, alles klar, wenn jetzt unsere Geräte alle Broadcom haben und die Airport Extreme auch Broadcom hat, dann können sie halt da so einen Boost-Modus einschalten, wenn man einen guten Empfang hat. Aber auch ansonsten haben die die Sendeleistung irgendwie reichlich erhöht. Und irgendwie der Typ bei Anantek meinte, der hat da Empfang in irgendwie Gegenden, wo er Vollausschlag hat jetzt, wo er früher irgendwie gar keinen Empfang hatte. Also es ist wohl alles Rock'n'Roll. Deswegen, Jungs, wenn ihr einen richtig guten WLAN-Empfang braucht, dann holt euch diese Station, die diesen Sommer rauskam. Müsst ihr aber gucken, man kann auf der Verpackung wohl nur irgendwie an so einer ganz kleinen Stelle überhaupt erkennen, dass es die fünfte Generation ist. Weil Apple hat wieder mal nichts gesagt und irgendwie ist es wieder so ein Silent-Update.
Wir reden jetzt nicht nur von dem Teil, was drei Terabyte-Platte drin hat.
Das ist eine Time-Capsule. Wir reden von Airport Extreme.
What's the difference? Dieses Review, von dem du da redest, testet beide gleichzeitig. Willst du mir erzählen, die sind unterschiedlich?
Was? Ich hab von Time-Capsule auch gar nichts gesagt.
Ja, aber was du für die Extreme, für die neue sagst, das gilt doch dann wohl auch für die Time-Capsule.
Ja, da waren irgendwie so ein paar Abstriche. Also nicht ganz, glaube ich. Da musst du nochmal genau gucken. Irgendwas war da. Aber so im Großen und Ganzen schon, ja.
Großen und Ganzen schon?
Ja, irgendwo meint er da, also irgendwas war dann bei der Time-Capsule doch noch ein bisschen anders. Ich weiß nicht genau, was. Bei einer Sache war es sogar noch ein Stück besser als die Xtreme. Ich glaube, bei 800211B, was wirklich niemand mehr benutzt da war, war die Time-Capsule irgendwie ein Stück besser. Irgendwie so was.
Besser noch?
Kann ja sein, dass er bei der anderen sich vermessen hat oder dass es halt da irgendwie keine Ahnung, Schwankungen in der Produktion gibt. Jedenfalls, wenn man richtig guten WLAN-Empfang haben will und eine uralte Station hat, weil von dieser Airport Extreme, ich hab mal geguckt, es gibt wirklich fünf Generationen. Der erste war mit 100 MBit, dann gab es einen Silent Upgrade auf Gigabit, dann kam die dritte Generation mit diesen Dual-Antennen oder Trippel schon, ich weiß gar nicht. Und dann gab es noch die vierte Generation auch nochmal damit und die fünfte ist jetzt halt wie gesagt auch immer noch das gleiche Motherboard, also hat sich überhaupt gar nichts geändert. Nur die WLAN-Karte hat sich halt zu Broadcom geändert und die fahren jetzt halt einen anderen WLAN-Stack, der irgendwie anscheinend so einen Boost-Modus hat, der irgendwie größere Pakete sendet, wenn der erkennt, dass auf der anderen Seite auch ein Broadcom ist und dann schieben sie noch ein bisschen mehr irgendwie rüber und gleichzeitig wurde die Sende-Power reichlich erhöht.
Klingt natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen so, als ob es nur dann besser ist, wenn man auf der anderen Seite noch einen Mac hat, der auch irgendwie denselben Chip hat. Das kann ja wohl jetzt nicht die einzige Optimierung sein, oder?
Naja, aber wir sind ja hier nun mal eine Mac-Sendung.
Ja, aber was ist, wenn du keinen Mac hast mit einem topaktuellen Super-Chip? Hast du dann auch besseren Empfang?
Das haben die da auch gemessen. Doch, der hat auch mit einem älteren MacBook Pro gemessen von 2009, glaube ich. Und das war da auch reichlich besser. Aber natürlich, wenn du das ganz neue MacBook Pro hast, auch mit diesem Broadcom-Chip, auch mit drei Antennen, die machen jetzt hier mit so Spatial-Antennen, dass er immer genau die richtige nimmt oder sogar beide gleichzeitig und so weiter, dann geht es richtig ab.
Okay, ich gucke mir gerade mal die Zahlen an. Das ist ja schon nennenswert hier. Also die Sendeleistung ist ja enorm gestiegen.
Ja, hat sich verdoppelt teilweise. Ja, aber gut, die Sendeleistung ist ja...
Sagt jetzt alleine nichts aus.
Genau, also...
Dürfen Sie denn Deutsch in Europa überhaupt vollfahren? So eine Sendleistung dann?
Gute Frage.
Na, dein Decktelefon macht bestimmt immer noch mehr Power.
Ja, ich glaub, da gibt es irgendwelche Begrenzung, was die Sendeleistung angehebt. Und das sieht ja gar nicht teilweise. Aber ich weiß es natürlich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall ist die Time Capsule und die AirPod Extreme dieselbe Technik, das wird hier relativ schnell klar. Ja, weil ich überleg auch, ich hab zweite Generation Time Capsule und ich hab definitiv Empfangsprobleme.
Also was ich halt habe ist...
Du meinst du hast zweite und dritte Generation oder wie?
Ich hab, ja, ich hab an einer einen Location, hab ich zweite Generation.
Und das hier ist die dritte Generation?
Hier, jetzt, im Studio, ja.
Ja, hab ich ja vorhin geguckt. Weil wenn man nämlich seine AirPod Utility aufmacht, da steht dann nämlich eindeutig da, wenn man die anklickt, dann steht nämlich hinten in Klammern Third Generation hier bei dir. Und daran erkennt man, was man für eine Station.
Hat.
Ja, also ich hab, so mit diesen, also zum Beispiel 5 Gigahertz, hab ich jetzt in der neuen Wohnung, geht nicht durch die Wände durch.
Das ist aber auch so ein bisschen klar, denn weil das...
Kurzwertig ist. Aber in der alten Wohnung war das so, dass ich mit 2,4 Gigahertz Probleme hatte und 5 Gigahertz ging super. Und jetzt halt in der neuen Wohnung ist so, hab ich dann auch 5 Gigahertz und 2,4 Gigahertz und wieder zwei Netze und irgendwann festgestellt, ja, das 5 Gigahertz Netz, das...
Ja, aber erst mal gucken, was deine Fritz-Boxen und wie viele Antennen haben oder ob die nur eine haben und wie viele Sendeleistungen die haben. Also auch schon so modernes Zeug.
Ja, das ist schon alles, das ist schon ziemlich weit vorn, das Ding. Also wie gesagt, ich glaube auch, ich glaube, das liegt, also ich weiß von Nachbarn, dass sie auch massive WLAN-Probleme haben in demselben Haus. Das muss irgendwie, weiß ja tausend was.
Vielleicht habt ihr da Metall...
Keine Ahnung... Irgendwie so was muss das sein. Oder irgendjemand hat einen kaputten Staubsauger, den ihr den ganzen Tag laufen lässt, der auf einem entsprechenden Frequenzband mitrödelt oder...
Was ja auch rausgekommen ist vor einiger Zeit, ist dieses Airport Utility, also dieses Dienstprogramm auf dem Mac. Gibt es jetzt auch in einer iOS-Version fürs iPhone. Und das ist beeindruckend, weil es im Gegensatz zu dem Mac-Programm, was ja dir nur so eine Liste von Geräten, die es sieht, macht, die ja so richtig die ganze Topologie aufzeigt. Genau, also genau weiß, welche... Ich hab so eine Airport Express-Kaskade irgendwie über die Straße und auch die hat er irgendwie erkannt und zeigt mir das dann so richtig an mit Bridge-Modus und so. Kann ich euch jetzt hier gerade nicht zeigen, hab keinen Screenshot gemacht. Von hier aus stellt sich das eben anders dar. Aber das ist bemerkenswert, dass sie da mehr Features drin haben als in der Mac-Version. Vielleicht fließt das auch nochmal zurück. Das wäre natürlich sehr sinnvoll. Aber auf jeden Fall kann man jetzt eben auch vom iPhone seinen Router ganz ordentlich administrieren. Das ist ja auch mal was. Apropos Apps, ich hab jetzt... Bevor wir das Thema verlassen, ich hab eigentlich gar keinen Bock auf einen Fritz-Box-Rand. Aber ich bin immer noch irgendwie unglücklich. Also es ist mir bis zum heutigen Tage, seitdem ich diese Fritz-Box jetzt hier für meinen VDSL installiert habe, weil ich zu voll war, mir so ein separates Modem zu holen, bin ich ein einziges Mal gelungen, hier mit Back to my Mac an meinen Rechner ranzukommen. Nicht nadern, jentel, rien.
Wenn man schon Apple-Fanboy ist, dann kann man da auch mal in die Tasche greifen. Und so schlecht sind die Airport-Extreme-Stationen jetzt nicht?
Ich hab ja hier so einen Teil. Ich hab so eine... Ja, aber die kannst du halt, die hat halt kein Modem eingebaut, also muss ich mir noch einen Modem separat kaufen. Weil ich mir das nicht mitgemietet habe. Weil ich mir dachte, brauch ich ja nicht, weil ich kann ja die Fritzbox da nehmen, aber das Ding als Modem zu nutzen und dann die Airport-Extreme quasi über die Fritzbox rauswählen zu lassen, das funktioniert nicht.
Was meinst du mit Modem?
Modem. DSL Modem.
Ist denn Airport-Extreme nicht drin?
Doch. Nein.
Was?
Apple hat generell nie Modems drin.
Klar.
Nein. N-E-I-N. Nein.
Du weißt nicht, das DSL-Kram, das können die schon, aber...
DSL Modem ist nicht drin.
Die können PPPoE, aber...
Die haben Ethernet und können...
PPPoE...
.können PPPoE reden, aber erst, wenn ein Modem das DSL auf Ethernet umgesetzt hat.
Ja, da waren ja so viele Geräte, ich komm noch mal durcheinander. Da brauchst du erst den Splitter, dann das Modem, dann den DSL-Router und so weiter.
Genau, der Splitter trägt DSL-Signal von ISDN oder Analog-Telefon und dann hast du halt das eigentliche DSL-Modem und das ist dann eben teilweise schon in die Router mit eingebaut. In der Fritzbox ist es halt mit drin und die dicke Fritzbox hat da eben auch vor DSL 2.
Aber im Apple-Teil nicht.
Aber im Apple-Teil halt nicht, was halt ein generelles Problem ist.
Brauchst halt ein Modem.
Brauch ich halt ein Modem, genau. War ich jetzt irgendwie zu faul mir eins zu mieten, weil ich auf sowas nicht stehe und dann dachte ich mir so, naja, halt diese Fritzbox rumliegen und so, wird schon irgendwie gehen.
Also wenn du jetzt in der Sendung sagst, dass du so ein Modem brauchst, ja, dann kommst du morgen nicht mehr durch die Tür, weil vor deiner Tür so ein Stapel Modems liegt, weil sie dir allein senden, weil natürlich alle so eine neue Fritzbox haben, die das kann und alle so ein Modem zu Hause irgendwie in der Ecke zu liegen haben, weil niemand braucht ihn denn.
Ich glaub, die gibt's nicht mehr so viel.
VDSL, weiß ich nicht, aber DSL Pro Plus, auf jeden Fall locker.
Die kriegst du ja auf eBay.
Nee, du kriegst heute deine Fritz-Box dazu.
Im Chat werd ich jetzt schon wieder drauf hingewiesen, dass das ja eigentlich alles geht und so. Und man kann ja auch irgendwie das irgendwie hinkriegen. Geht aber nicht. Das geht aber nicht. Ich krieg's nicht hin. Vielleicht bin ich jetzt einfach zu blöd, aber das geht aber nicht.
Also ich kauf mir demnächst irgendwann mal so einen Airport-Extrem und dann ist bei mir zu Hause alles schick, schnell und so weiter. Und da das Ding ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen Miniswitch ist, kann ich dann auch da meinen Switch entfernen und dann hab ich wieder ein Gerät weniger, was in der Steckdose drin ist. Und dann lass mal Ruhe. Dann hab ich Empfang im Bett ohne Ruckeln.
Dann bin ich das Problem, wenn wir los und dann...
Ey, wir haben über 600 Live-Höre jetzt. Kau mal das Huckele nicht da und dann geht's ab hier.
Aber wir haben keine Themen. Bin man auch nicht? Nein, wir rodern rum hier. Occupy Flash.
Ich hab das aufgeschrieben, genau.
Ich bin unschuldig.
Occupy Flash ist halt so...
Man soll doch nicht auf tote Pferde einschlagen.
Es gibt auch Occupy HTML. Ich hab mir aber von Beides Manifest nicht durchgelesen. Occupy Flash ist so halt, ja, wir müssen jetzt Flash mal fertig machen und Flash muss weg. Und Occupy HTML ist dann auch so eine Gegen-Webseite, die sagt dafür, jede Technologie dafür einsetzen, wofür sie am besten taucht. Und auch Flash hat seine Darsens-Berechtigung.
Bestimmt, aber nicht auf meinem Rechner.
Willst du installieren, gefälligst Flash?
Ich hab Flash installiert. Achso. Aber ich hab auch clickte Flash installiert. Das heißt, ich weiß ganz genau, was ich klicken will und wann nicht und oft nicht.
Damit scherpest hast du aber die Situation. Ich finde, du könntest mir Opfer zeigen.
Wie auch Flash wegmachen, richtig?
Dein Browser sagt immer noch dem Server, dass du Flash hast.
Du meinst, dann wird es nie weggehen. Aber die sehen auch, dass ich es nicht starte, oder?
Es gibt jetzt schon Webseiten, die kriegen es auch hin. Das setzt sich durch. Das ist schwer. Das ist eine der schwierigsten Transitionen durch dieses Netz je gehen musste, aber es muss.
Als ich gestern auf der Baden-Württembergischen Statistiken für das Statistischen Landesamt auf der Webseite war, um mir die S21-Resultate anzuschauen. Die hatten da auf dem iPad, wurde mir freudig berichtet, dass sie ein Java-Applet hätten, mit dem man interaktiv die Sachen sich angucken kann, die Ergebnisse. Das gibt's auch noch. Und ich meine, die sollten Statistiken haben, wie viele Java-User sie noch haben, also wie viele Leute noch Java installiert haben.
Das sind so deutsche Behörden, die stehen total auf diese Java.
Die sind halt immer zehn Jahre hinterher und kommen gerade da an, wo alle anderen gerade weggehen.
Eigentlich total schade, weil diese Statistikseiten zu wahlen oder sowas, die haben die ganzen aktuellen Informationen, die brauchen dann nur noch einen Ticker durchzupacken, wo man sieht, wie leuchten Zahlen. Als Wahljunkie, wo geht es gerade ab, dann kannst du dir die ganzen Politiker fressen, könntest dir sparen und Spiegel online und dieses ganze Getöse. Und könntest einfach schön auf den Statistikseiten rumsurfen. Die könnten so eine geile Anlaufstelle werden für so eine Zahl, das wäre ja...
Occupy Java.
Occupy Statistisches Landesamt.
Ja, was soll man sagen?
Hoffentlich sieht nichts mich so wahr, denn ich spiel.
Ich bringe jetzt mal mein Doom-Thema ein.
Doom-Thema oder Jugend-Thema? Doom.
Wir sind alle doomed. Vor ein paar Tagen wurde Doom 3, der Sourcecode, veröffentlicht. Und habe ich mich erstmal nicht weiter drum gekümmert, weil ja, Sourcecode ist jetzt... Also, naja, ist halt so Grafiker-Sourcecode. Also hier so Render-Engines. Das ist nicht so meine Ecke eigentlich. Und dann gab es aber vor ein paar Tagen, ich glaube, Samstag habe ich es entdeckt, so eine Seite, kann ich auch mal posten irgendwie, wo so ein Franzose, glaube ich, zumindest hat er einen französisch klingenden Namen, eine Anleitung gemacht hat, wie man Doom 3 dann halt mit Xcode kompiliert. Weil vorher gab es da wohl halt noch voll Ärger, lief auch nicht mit LLVM oder ZLan, konnte man es nicht kompilieren. Und auch so irgendwie gab es da noch irgendwie Schwierigkeiten beim Bauen. Und der hat sich dem angenommen. Und da gibt es jetzt eine schicke Seite. Man kann das wirklich irgendwie aus GitHub auschecken oder irgendwie runterladen. Und dann drückt bei Xcode irgendwie compile oder build heißt es ja. Und schwuppdiwupp, eine Minute später, also zumindest auf meinem Quad-Core, da wird er auch richtig mal ausgenutzt mit all seinen Cores. Eine Minute später oder zwei fällt irgendwie da das fertige Doom raus. Und inzwischen, am Anfang hat es noch ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten gemacht, aber inzwischen geht es. Die Key-Up-Frage ist auch raus, weil es ist ja jetzt frei. Und wenn man noch einen Doom von früher hat, also diese Game-Daten, weil die sind ja nicht frei.
Achso, das ist wieder nur das eigentliche.
Wieder nur das, wie soll man sagen, die Engine ist frei, aber das Spiel-Content natürlich nicht. Und wenn man die aber noch hat oder sich kauft, kostet wohl gerade 10 Euro bei Stream, Steam heißt es ja, dann kann man das zocken. Und ich hab das gemacht und das funktioniert.
Gibt's Doom jetzt schon auf dem iPad?
Na, das Doom nicht. Obwohl doch, da gab's doch irgendwas, oder?
Also wär jetzt wahrscheinlich dann relativ easy, oder?
Wir haben noch so einen Doom on Rails, oder so, weißt schon, wie der so...
Doom on Rails?
Naja, wo du so lang gefahren wirst, wo du nicht links und rechts... Du kannst nicht nur drehen, aber der läuft für dich automatisch.
Nee, aber jetzt einfach diesen Quellcode nehmen und auf dem iPad oder auf dem iPhone...
Weiß ich nicht, kommt bestimmt auch irgendwann.
Muss doch gehen.
Jedenfalls fand ich es ganz witzig da mal, das auch alles mit C lang irgendwie oder Klang einmal durchzukompilen.
Klang.
Und Timmy klickt hier immer noch. Airport Extreme ist cool, ne? Die anderen Tech-Jungs, die machen es echt so, dass es Spaß macht, sich das alles durchzulesen, obwohl man eben genau nicht meckert, dass man sich halt genau mit dem Zeug eigentlich sich nicht beschäftigen muss. Okay, weil dann das vielleicht auch andere machen. Ja, mir hat es auch Spaß gemacht, den durchzulesen. Ich fand es auch gut.
Hochbestückte Platinen reckeln sich nackt vor ihnen. Schau dir an die Beinchen von dem Chip.
Ja, so macht das aber heute auch keiner mehr.
Ah, naja gut, ich meine hier diese...
So mach ich das, das ist nur der Deckel.
Diese MacFixit-Jungs, die sind ja auch immer ganz gut, wenn es um Auspackporn geht. Aber das finde ich irgendwie gut. Ist ja überhaupt so gut, dass es überhaupt noch Leute gibt, die irgendwie überhaupt irgendwas davon verstehen.
Und was ich gut finde, ist, dass die Leute jetzt auch auf Mac angekommen sind. Also früher war es ja schon so ein bisschen Mangelware, so Leute, die sich so ein bisschen ganz tief unten drunten irgendwie auskannten. Und da gibt es jetzt halt ein bisschen mehr von. Und man findet jetzt auch immer so mehr Infos darüber. Also auch so Sachen wie, dass der Key aus der Erfurt Express da rausgehackt wurde. Das hätte es früher auch nicht so einfach mal gegeben.
Na ja, hat ja auch lang genug gedauert, oder?
Ja, weil es sie früher halt nicht gegeben hat. Also bis halt die Hacker mal alle auf dem Mac angekommen sind.
Wobei der hat doch auch erzählt, dass er nur die Airport-Extremes der Express seiner Freundin...
Ja, das stimmt. Und das Schlimmste am Öffnen war irgendwie, dass er sich die Hände zerkratzert an diesem Scheißgehäuse.
Und die Nägel abgeboren sind.
Irgendwie so. Und den Key da rauskriegen war wohl weniger schwierig. Was mir noch eingefallen ist, muss ich jetzt nochmal sagen, ich musste das mit dem Airport Extreme nochmal aufgreifen. Also Time Capsule. Wenn da doch, wie du schon sagst, und man kann es glaube ich auch hier auf der iPhone App, an dieses Airport Utility auf dem iPhone, habe ich mal irgendwie die Copyright Notes da und so angeguckt. Und dann müssen die das ganze GPL Zeug, sowas auch immer, die benutzen, da müssen die einmal so auflisten. Und dann steht halt auch da, dass da halt irgendwie so NetBSD sich da irgendwie Copyright und so haben. Das heißt also da ist ja NetBSD drin, so war es ja.
So war es, ich weiß nicht, ist es immer noch so vermutlich?
Ich nehme an, weil es steht da auch immer noch so dieser Copyright halt so drin, plus noch einiges andere an Software, was die da so benutzen. So und dann müsste ja eigentlich auf dieser Time-Capsule auch so eine Art Net-A-Talk laufen, weil die ja da höchstwahrscheinlich, also wenn man die Platte abstecken kann, die da am USB dran ist, dann HFS fahren, richtig? Also da muss dann ein HFS-Filesystem drauf sein und dann muss noch was, damit man mit AFS da zugreifen kann, muss da auch noch irgendwie AFP drauf sein. Wenn die da einen AFP von Apple drauf haben, auf diesem NetBSD, warum hat das noch keiner extrahiert? Also das will man noch eigentlich haben, weil die haben da das neueste, geilste irgendwie AFS-Version mit einem Schnickschnack und einem Support.
Das heißt extrahiert, ich meine, das ist Binary.
Ja und?
Binary für, was ist da für ein Stein?
Stimmt, da ist ein Arm drin. Ja, das könnte Apple, gibt's das nicht irgendwie als, das gibt's nicht als offen, ne? Weil dieses Netatalk ist immer noch so...
Man kann ganz schwer davon ausgehen, dass es sich bei dem Code im Wesentlichen um den Code von MechOS X handelt. Angepasst eben auf NetBSD.
Also wahrscheinlich wär's einfacher, das auszupassen.
Sollen die den mal rausrücken?
Tja, naja, ist er ja eigentlich, den gibt's ja. Der ist ja bei Darwin, kannst du das ja im Source runterladen.
Ja eben, weil sonst hätten die den doch genommen und hätten den bei FreeBSD doch irgendwie mal... Also dann würd's doch so einen Port davon geben, dann müsste man sich mit diesem Netatalk sich nicht rumärgern. Oder dann würd's zumindest zwei Implementationen geben, wo man irgendwie abwiegen kann, welche von beiden man jetzt besser findet. Ich will ja nicht sagen, dass Netatalk scheiße ist. Ich benutze es ja seit Jahren und bin ja eigentlich schon ganz happy.
Oh Gott, ich hab einen Netatalk mit der 1.4. Version oder so was. Hätte ich mal so um ein Haar komplett wahnsinnig viele Daten verloren.
Um ein Haar aber nur.
Ja, aber das war schon echt schlimm. Und zwar hatten die, das war damals noch so auf irgendeinem alten Apple Talk basierend mit File Reference Numbers. Kennt ihr das noch? Und die kippten um bei 32.000. Das sind maximal 32.000 Dateien und dann fingen die wieder bei 16-Bit oder 65.000 wahrscheinlich dann. Und dann waren auf diesem nette Talk-Volume plötzlich mehr als 65.000 Dateien drauf mit dem Ergebnis, dass du hast eine Datei doppelt geklickt und eine komplett anderes aufgegangen. Und dann haben die halt, dachte ich, okay, schalte ich nette Talk ab, gucke auf der Platte nach, auf dem Original und hole die Daten darunter, aber da hast du dann wieder diese damals noch existierende Trennung zwischen Data und Resource Fork gehabt. Und da waren zwei Dateien abgelegt. Das heißt, der einzigen Weg, den ich damals gefunden habe, die wieder zusammenzuführen, war über nette Talk. Und dann habe ich das System aufgeholt, also die Dateien teilweise rausgeholt, dann immer so schrittweise die Dateien drüber holen, um unter diesem Limit zu bleiben. Das war so ein Pain in the ass. Danach habe ich nette Talk untergeschmissen von der Kiste. Aber das haben sie dann mit dem 2-0 dann hingebogen. Aber das hat sich auch so ewig hingezogen mit der 2-0. Das war dann ewig lang im Alpha-Stadium. Och, nie wieder. Du unterhältst dich hier wieder mit dem Chat heimlich?
Ja, ich werde da angesprochen.
So, ja, das Doom-Thema ist durch, war auch ganz schnell abgehakt. Dann hab ich noch ein Mini-Thema. Letzte Woche hab ich ja erzählt, also vor zwei Wochen, dass es dieses Webkit, oder war das schon vor vier Wochen, keine Ahnung, dass es 100.000 Revisionen bei Webkit gibt. Und dann irgendwie nachdem ich das auch erzählt habe, gleich ein, zwei Tage später lade ich mir wie immer das neueste Webkit runter. Also das Nightly-Bild. Und seitdem, wenn ich bei Spiegels, Scrolle, Ruckels, wie es aussah, hab ich mir drei, vier Tage angeguckt und nachdem es nicht besser wurde, habe ich so Open Source-mäßig, macht man es ja, ne? Habe ich irgendwie hier meinen Kolokwai aufgemacht, bin in den Webkit-Channel reingegangen und habe gesagt, ey Jungs, hier, wat ist los? Mein Spiegel ruckelt. Dann kam gleich irgendwie ein Simon Fraser oder so. Meinte, ja, stimmt, kann er auch nachvollziehen. Da hab ich ihm geschrieben, ja so, Spiegel so, größte Newsseite Deutschlands und so, wie sieht's aus? Meinte, ja, alles klar. Er macht da mal ein Ticket auf. Mich nicht weiter gekümmert. Nach einer Weile guck ich wieder in Chat. Hat er mir die Ticketnummer gepostet, war halt hier so bei WebKit, haben ja diesen Bug Tracker. Hab ich mir das Ticket angeguckt. Hat er halt schön geöffnet, hat gesagt, hier zwischen der Revision und der Revision, hier so Regression, also weil früher ging's mal jetzt nicht mehr. Das hat ja bei denen immer gleich höhere Priorität, wenn was nicht mehr geht. Und dann hat er auch gleich hier irgendwie, hat er einen Tag gesetzt, dass er das im Radar, das ist dieser interne Apple Bug Tracker, hat er das Ding da gleich auch gesetzt, weil wenn die demnächst irgendwie einen neuen Safari rausbringen, ja, und der Spiegel ruckelt, geht mal gar nicht. Also Jungs, jeder der den Webkit benutzt, bei dem jetzt der Spiegel ruckelt, ist alle unter Kontrolle.
Hoffe ich. Achso, ich dachte jetzt kommt so die Story, wie denn der Bug 10 Minuten später gefixt war.
Nee leider nicht, es hat schon wieder eine Woche rum.
Also Webkit kann man sozusagen gerade auch nicht fahren.
Nee, man braucht eine Revision, die letzte von den Nightly Builds, die man irgendwie benutzen kann ist, wo ist mein Downloads hier, ist die 100.143, die geht noch bei den Nightly Builds, alle danach, da ruckelt das Spiegel.
Der Spiegel ruckelt.
Achso, und das ist ein JavaScript-Dingens natürlich. Also JavaScript kriegt Events beim Scrollen irgendwie mit. Und dann, das JavaScript kackt dabei voll ab und macht alles voll langsam. Wenn man mit den Cursor-Tasten scrollt oder richtig die Scrollbar benutzt, dann kriegt das JavaScript anscheinend keine Events und dann ist alles okay.
Scroll-Events müssen die da in jedem Fall kriegen.
Nee, es sind wahrscheinlich mehr so, wie du mit deiner Maus da so langziehst oder so. Keine Ahnung, was da der Unterschied ist. Also es muss irgendwie da einen Unterschied machen.
Ich würde sagen, das ist eine Pelamentierungsfehler auf Apple-Seite.
Ja, es ist ja so oder so. Ich kann ja noch mal gucken, aber ich glaube, da ist bisher noch nichts passiert. Es wird eines Tages Plop machen.
Vielleicht schießen die das entsprechende Did-Scroll-Event oder was auch immer das heißt. Zu häufig abwenden mit einem Checkmate-Scroll.
Kann alles sein. Wie hat das genannt? Terrible Hangs and Performance Issues on www.spiegel.de Da kann ich noch mal ein bisschen zu erzählen.
Ich hab jetzt hier ein Kollege von mir, Rob von Soundcloud, der hat die schöne Seite inunico.de Das ist sowas, wenn man mal so ein Unico-Zeichen braucht, zum Beispiel mal ein Multiply-Zeichen oder sowas, dann kann man einfach anfangen zu suchen. Also es ist eine total simple Seite, hat einen Suchfeld. Du fängst an einzugeben, was du gerne... inunico.de Ohne de. Genau. So, genau. Und dann fängst du an, jetzt gibst du da zum Beispiel was weiß ich, Snow oder Multiply oder halt welches Zeichen du auch immer suchst. Und dann siehst du die entsprechenden Unicode-Zeichen, die darauf passen, zum Beispiel in Snowman.
Aber warum nimmst du nicht das Appletool? Da gibt es doch hier direkt in jedem Programm einen Special Characters. Ich tippe mal da Snow ein.
Das geht auch. Ich finde das...
Dann kommen die da auch.
Ich finde diese Tool-Palette von Apple, ich finde die... Ich meine, da muss man erst... Da hat man diesen... Da muss man dieses Menü oben einschalten. Und wie kommst du da ran an diese Palette?
Also er zeigt mir jetzt Zeichen ein und davon...
Hier, die ist doch da. In Edit ist die immer da. Ganz unten Edit Special Characters. Also ich hab jetzt hier Englisch.
Wovon redet ihr gerade?
Von Special Characters im Edit-Menü. Da gibt es sozusagen auch das Feature. Davon reden wir gerade. Wolltest du wissen?
Nee, das wollte ich nicht wissen.
Du hast gefragt wovon wir gerade reden.
Trotzdem habe ich hier in deinem Browser gerade drei von diesen sieben Zeichen.
Ja klar, der gibt ja halt alle. Na ja, wo soll er denn wissen, welche dein Browser kann und welche davon nicht?
Nee, das weiß er nicht. Aber mein Computer hat mal alle zu können. Ich meine, warum habe ich keinen Black Snowman auf meiner Webseite?
Wobei irgendwie, der Snowman without Snow, den kann zumindest dein iPhone... Achso, mit Line? Siehst du, mit Installer Line kannst du das Snowman without Snow.
Ich trau mich immer noch nicht, hier auf Line zu gehen. Obwohl ich es jetzt wahrscheinlich demnächst tun werde, aber ich bin so unglücklich. binunglücklich.de Das hab ich letztes Mal schon gesagt, stimmt's?
Jaja, bei mir kommt hier Unicon-Site. Was hab ich falsch gemacht?
Auf Line gibt's auch keinen Black Snowman.
Wo gibt's denn?
Aber es gibt einen Snowboarder.
Doch, also hier in Safari, da gibt's den.
Nee, den Black nicht, aber die beiden anderen gibt's immerhin.
Snowman without Snow gibt's.
Ja, aber kein Black Snowman.
Naja, ich sag ja einen mehr.
Und der Snowman without, der ist sogar in Graustufen.
Genau, so ein E-Modulzeichen.
Nicht nur Graustufen, der ist bunt.
Auf jeden Fall hab ich da mal angefangen, Spaßes halber auch so ein Programm draus zu machen, was oben auch in der Menüleiste drin ist, wo man dann auch vernünftig mitsuchen kann.
Ach cool, dann kann man aber auch snowman.inunico.de eingeben und dann hat man...
Genau, man hat auch die, man hat dann immer noch die perma...
In groß. Ach das ist ja hübsch.
Und wenn man mit Apfel A auswählt, hat er extra viel Wert drauf gelegt, hat er den entsprechenden CSS-Selektor gemacht für...
Dass man nur das Zeichen selektiert.
Dass man nur das Zeichen selektiert und nicht die Beschreibung dazu. Also es ist schon echt ganz cool gemacht.
Na dieses Feature, wenn du halt hier auf den Snowman draufklickst, dann kriegst du halt snowman.inunico.de und wenn du dann einen Apfel a-maßt, dann selektiert er dir auch wirklich nur den.
Genau, falls man also was öfters braucht, da hat man das dann immer schön schnell da. Find ich wesentlich...
Die sieht aber wirklich strange aus, dieser Snowman.
Auf jeden Fall hab ich da beschlossen, mal jetzt quasi eine Mac-App draus zu machen, aus dem Ding, die dann auch in einer Menüleiste lebt oder per systemweiten Shortcut funktioniert und hab damit mal so an die klassische Coco-Entwicklung...
Spotlight-Plugin, gibt's sowas eigentlich?
Für Unicode-Zeichen?
Ja, wenn die auch rechnen können, können die auch andere Sachen?
Stimmt, das wär eigentlich ne Lust... Obwohl ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich vernünftig anzeigen können.
Also wenn ich in Spotlight rechnen kann, glaube ich, hab ich ganz ganz selten, hol ich nur noch den Calculator raus.
Na ja, ich nehm zum Rechnen immer Launchbar.
Also das ist am Ende dasselbe. Also dein Quick-Eintipp-Ersatz halt.
Jaja, genau. Ja, also das sowieso. Aber da muss ich mal sagen, das ist ja... Hier Mac-Programmierung ist ja schon ein bisschen was anderes als iOS-Programmierung. Die Unterschiede sind jetzt nicht gigantisch, aber ich hab schon das Gefühl, dass sie das... Also man merkt, dass sie bei iOS schon wussten, wie man so eine API entwickelt, während bei MacOS, beim klassischen Coco, noch wesentlich mehr improvisiert oder mehr um-explantiert worden ist.
Ist aufgeräumter beim iPhone. Aber ist ja auch schon ein bisschen... Das MacOS-API ist halt schon ein bisschen mehr gewachsen. Da geht ja auch ein bisschen mehr. Du kannst ja auch mehr rumschlampen und viel mehr machen als auf dem iPhone.
Ja, aber ich finde, die iOS-API, also UI Touch, ist wesentlich stringenter. Du kennst einmal den Ansatz.
Der Apple Garden ist da noch wesentlich kleiner, aber auch deswegen.
Ja, aber ich meine zum Beispiel hier diese Protokolle, diese überall. Die sind ja auf iOS wirklich durchgängig. Du hast ein Delegate, darum ist ein Protokoll implementiert. Da musst du einfach nur das Protokoll ran schreiben und alles ist gut. Da hast du ja bei Coco noch diverse andere Sachen. Also diese Methodennamen, die teilweise ja unter Coco mit, also Getter, der heißt dann IS irgendwas, also IS-viable Name und der heißt manchmal mit IS, manchmal ohne IS, ist unter UI-Touch konsequent ohne IS vorne, sodass du immer weißt, wie die Methode heißt.
Weil sie diese Dot-Notation haben.
Genau, weil sie diese Dot-Notation haben, konsequent durchgängig und konstanten Namen, finde ich krass, um wie viel besser die unter iOS sind. Weil die heißen vorne immer identisch, also was weiß ich, was wende. UI-View, Autoresize, Flexible Width. UI-View, Autoresize, Flexible Height. UI und so weiter und so fort. Der Anfang ist immer gleich so, dass wenn du anfängst zu tippen und dir nur anguckst, was die Autocompletion macht, dann weißt du, welche Optionen dir zur Verfügung stehen. Und du suchst nicht so ewig lange rum, wie wenn direkt das zweite Zeichen anders heißt. Ich finde das echt krass, wie viel das auch anders ist bei IOS als bei Mac.
Ich bin aus Prokrastinierungsgründen gerade an meiner Pool-Software rumkoden wie ein Bekloppte. Ich will es so schnell wie möglich haben und optimieren von weniger Pakete senden bis anstatt TCP-Connections Unit-Sockets-Domains einzusetzen und auch Lippevent und Jansson und Lippcurl zu benutzen. Was die da so an Apis haben, da kommt mir teilweise das Grauen. Bei Cocoa oder von mir aus auch auf dem iPhone ist alles schön aufgeräumt und logisch benannt. Auch die Garbage Collection ist halt, du willst ja vielleicht jetzt machst du dieses ARC und hast auf den anderen Scheiß keinen Bock mehr, versteh ich auch. Aber ich kenn mich da noch aus mit Alloc und Copy und Retain, da musst du halt releasen und ansonsten halt nicht. Und es ist irgendwie eine simple Regel, passt auf eine kleine Seite und dann ist alles klar. Und bei diesem Jansson, also so eine Jason-Lipp irgendwie, dann haben die damit borrowed references und wenn du so nicht selber freigeben musst, dann kannst du den Call mit einem New hinten dran irgendwie benutzen, was mir nicht klar ist, warum man einen New hinten dran hängt, wenn man was danach nicht releasen muss. Also die ganze Benamung ist mir alles irgendwie nicht sehr intuitiv irgendwie. Wobei ist das? Na du kannst auch in diesem Jason irgendwie Objekte machen, so. Da machst du Strings zu so einem Jason-Objekt und wenn du das irgendwo benutzt, dann haben die auch so einen Reference Count und da musst du auch irgendwie so de-decrement Reference Count irgendwie rufen, um den wieder eins runter zu setzen. So wenn du aber dein Objekt irgendwo weiter reichen willst und danach nicht mehr selber brauchst, müsstest du es also weiter reichen und danach de-crementieren. Und damit du das aber nicht beides callen musst, kannst du ihn weiter reichen mit einem Call, der auch New hinten dran hast und dann musst du ihn nicht mehr de-crementieren. Dann hast du sozusagen schon gleich auch frei gegeben mit...
Also ein Autorelease.
Sozusagen, aber das heißt halt New. Also bla bla, Set Object, New. Und dann de-crementiert er automatisch für dich und dann verstehe ich nicht... Nee, nee, das ist so eine Jason-C-Lib. Aber das wollte ich halt sagen. Also mir ist da die API und wie die ihre Methoden und Funktionen und so weiter alles nennen. Na, weil das da schon drin ist. Und mein Push-Pull-Demon, der hat irgendwie so einen Code, der nutzt den und ich hab das alles mal schneller und besser gemacht und bin halt am Optimieren gerade, wie blöd. Und ja, also wenn man da mal ein bisschen über den Tellerrand guckt, dann sieht man mal, was es da noch so alles gibt. Und das sieht teilweise nicht schön aus.
Ja, schöne Einblicke ins Programmiererleben. Ich hab mich da mal ganz rausgehalten. Mich hat ja immer das Programmieren auf Mac gar nicht so gezogen.
Nee, es hat mich auch nicht gezogen. Ich hab ja mir...
Ist es mittlerweile täglich?
Unter OS 9 habe ich mir den CodeVariier-Compiler gekauft. Ich dachte, so ein Computer ohne Compiler ist ja irgendwie nichts Richtiges. Aber unter hier Mac OS 9 oder 8 oder 7, das...
Also ich hab das gemacht.
Ging gar nicht. Außer so Terminal-mäßige... Ja, so Command-Line-Tools, so zu coden, die man dann auf dem Mac ausführt, wo so eine kleine CodeVariier-Shell aufgeht. Also keine Shell, aber so ein... Ach so ein MPW-Window. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man es nennen soll. Das war ja keine Shell. Aber so ein Zeilen-Ausgabefenster. Das habe ich noch gekodet, wo man halt mit Print auf irgendwie Ausgaben macht, wo so Zeug berechnet wird oder was weiß ich nicht alles. Das ging noch, aber so irgendwas mit GUI oder QuickTime oder sonst wie. Es ging alles gar nicht. Also es war horrible.
Also was ich, ich habe ja...
Das geht für heute noch nicht so richtig.
Ich habe mit QuickTime, na QuickTime weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, wie wir das mittlerweile taugt. QuickTime 10 soll ja angeblich komplett neu. Also ich habe das letztes...
Ja, das ist komplett neu und kann halt nicht alles, was...
Na ich habe doch für das Display im Club, habe ich ein kleines Tool gebaut, wo du einen QuickTime-kompatiblen Film drauf schmeißen kannst. Der rechnet den dann runter in schwarz-weiß Monochrom für halt in der Display-Größe, also das Display, was da im Club hängt, und schiebt den dann rüber in Realtime. Und da habe ich halt eine QuickTime View und QuickTime... QT-Kit heißt es. Heißt es QT, ja doch, QuickTime-Kit. Ja doch, QT-Kit heißt es. Und da kannst du halt den Film entweder direkt abspielen und aktuell das Bild geben lassen, was gerade während er das abspielt, oder du kannst irgendwie eine Zeit angeben von dem Movie und du sagst, gib mir mal das Bild, was an Sekunde 5 ist, jetzt gib mir mal das Bild, was an Sekunde 6 ist, nur dass du es halt ein bisschen öfter machst. Und die hole ich mir dann halt 25 mal die Sekunde und schiebe die dann an mein Display. Und das war, also ich glaube, ich hatte irgendwann die Idee, das zu machen. Die ganze Framework für Bilder zum Display schicken, hatte ich schon, also dass ich so ein Bild mit Drag & Drop drauffallen lasse auf mein Tool und dann wird es automatisch auf dem Display angezeigt. Und ich glaube, bis ich das hatte, dass ein Film da angezeigt wird, das dauerte eine Stunde gekostet oder so. Das ging wirklich, also ich bin dann immer so ein bisschen enttäuscht, wenn ich denke, ok, jetzt hab ich mal richtig Lust und Bock und will was koden und setze mich so ran und dann bin ich nach einer Stunde schon mehr oder weniger fertig. Da bin ich immer so ein bisschen enttäuscht und denke so, ja das war's jetzt und das ist ja scheiße, ich wollte auch eigentlich so richtig geil koden und dann war's viel zu schnell fertig.
Also um jetzt mal deine Frage so aus meiner Perspektive ein bisschen zu beantworten, ob das denn mittlerweile erträglich geworden ist, ich hab das letzte Mal programmiert, das war so zur System-Siebenzeiten davor. Das war noch Pascal und das war mit den dicken Inside-Macintosh-Büchern, die man dann unbedingt noch brauchte, um da überhaupt irgendwas auf die Reihe zu kriegen und wurde dir ewig viele Windows-Pointer. Und ich weiß noch, dass man eigentlich neulich erzählt, ein Default-Button, also so ein Button, den man per Return-Anruf aufrufen wollte, da musstest du den Button, dafür gab's ein System-Call und dann musstest du selber einen drei oder vier Pixel breiten Rounded Rect drum rum schalten. Es gab nicht einfach irgendwie ne Eigenschaft von diesem Button, mit dem du sagen konnt, sei mal Default-Button, sondern musstest du selber drum. Und da war auch im Inside Mac, direkt im ersten Kapitel, war irgendwie erklärt, wie das geht. Und dann bin ich halt davon abgekommen und hab zuerst mit Real Basic gemacht und dann immer weiter so in diese Web-Entwicklung rein, weil das geht halt einfach schneller, der Scheiß, und du kommst schneller zum Ziel und so. Und jetzt, und Mac OS X muss am Anfang auch Pain in the Ass gewesen sein, glaube ich. Weil das alles noch nicht fertig war. Und auch iOS muss ja am Anfang ganz schlimm gewesen sein, als die ganzen Tools noch nicht funktioniert haben. Und dieses ganze Zeug. jetzt bin ich hab ich wieder damit angefangen und bin extrem erstaunt, genauso wie du sagst, wie schnell man jetzt zum Ziel kommt. Zum einen, weil die Werkzeuge tatsächlich besser geworden sind. Zum zweiten, weil man dank Stack Overflow, muss man ja auch mal sagen, das ist ja wirklich die Quelle überhaupt.
Ja und dank Internet war jetzt wirklich jeder Arsch und sein Bruder gecoded fürs iPhone. Also ist alles voll davon, mit Leuten die Fragen stellen und auch voll davon Gott sei Dank mit Leuten, die es beantworten.
Ja und das finde ich jetzt gerade bei Objective-C, finde ich das noch eigentlich um einiges krasser, wie viele Libraries es da gibt. Also die sind teilweise in einem erbärmlichen Zustand, aber dieser Shortcut-Recorder zum Beispiel, der in jedem Projekt drin ist. Also wenn man irgendwie so diese Standard, wenn man selber irgendwelche Tastenkürzel festlegen kann, dann ist das mit 90% der Wahrscheinlichkeit der Shortcut-Recorder, was ein furchtbar umgepflegtes Projekt ist, was angeblich auch liegt ohne Ende, aber wenn man es nicht so oft aufruft, dann geht es wahrscheinlich. Aber es gibt halt für hunderte Einsatzfälle, gibt es schon was. Und ich glaube, also zum Beispiel wollte ich immer mit SQlite was machen. Und dann kannst du mit diesen Core Foundation-Funktion für SQlite anfangen, was ja auch furchtbar ist. Und dann gibt es hier, wie heißt es, FFDB oder so? Mal gucken, wie das heißt. Moment. Was das dann auch alles schön weg abstrahiert und daraus ein nettes FMDB, so heißt es. Und womit man dann schön per Coco auf SQlite zugreifen kann. Das ist schon alles tausendmal besser geworden, als damals, als ich mich noch daran erinnert habe.
Und vor allem jetzt irgendwie ganze Autokomplichen und Doku lesen mit einer SSD ist ja auch ziemlich geil, weil es einfach alles Ratsfahrt sofort instantmäßig irgendwie vorgeschlagen wird. Und das war ja auch mal nicht so schnell. Du kannst dir ja vorstellen, wie langsam das war.
Na die Doku könnte man halt wegen, also dieses Organizer-Fenster, wenn man da anfängt zu tippen und dann irgendwie, wie lange das braucht, das finde ich ja tatsächlich...
Ja, gewisse Sachen bei X-Foot 4 sind immer noch Schrott, ja das stimmt. Also...
Da geht noch was.
Was habt ihr denn so euch vorgenommen fürs... Vielleicht schon zu früh, weil wir haben ja noch eine Sendung dieses Jahr, aber habt ihr schon so gute Vorsätze fürs nächste Jahr, was euer Leben mit dem Mac betrifft?
Wie jetzt?
Weiß nicht, irgendwelche Ziele, Dinge, die du schon immer mal tun wolltest. Also ich hab ja letztes Jahr vorgenommen, eine Programmiersprache zu lernen, eine neue.
Letztes Jahr, und hast du es auch gemacht?
Ja.
Und was war es? Erlang. Und hast du es gelernt?
Ich verstehe es. Nicht, dass ich besonders viel Zeit gehabt hätte zu coden. Aber ich denke, soweit eingestiegen zu sein, dass ich ganz angeregt mich darüber unterhalten kann. Ich hab keinen Running Code vorzuweisen. Aber mir war die Auseinandersetzung damit wichtig, weil man muss einfach mal... Man muss auch mal andere... Ja, ich hab ja auch da so diverse Ziele gehabt, die konnten dann aus bestimmten Gründen nicht so richtig verwirklicht werden. Aber wichtig ist, dass man sich mal wieder was anderes anschaut. Und ich frage mich, was man sich halt sonst noch mal so anschauen sollte.
Programmiersprachemäßig oder grundsätzlich?
Grundsätzlich eigentlich. Programmiersprachen finde ich von daher immer sehr interessant, weil sie einem einfach... Erlang hat mir echt nochmal ein paar wirklich neue Ansätze gezeigt. Da hab ich einfach angefangen über ein paar Sachen wirklich anders nachzudenken, als ich das bisher getan habe. Das finde ich schult das technische Verständnis grundsätzlich sehr. Auch das Herangehen an Software, Softwaredesign und das ist ja schon ein Feld, was mich interessiert, was nicht für jeden was ist. Aber wenn man sowieso schon programmiert, denke ich, das Beste, was man tun kann, ist, dass man jedes Jahr eine neue Programmiersprache lernt. Das heißt nicht, dass man jetzt in dieser Programmiersprache unglaublich viel schreiben muss oder so, sondern nur, dass man sie lernt. Dass man einfach nur sich damit vertraut macht und merkt, dass die eigene Programmiersprache nicht alles ist.
Du meinst grundsätzlich neue Ansätze sich mal angucken. Erlang ist ja ziemlich viel so multi-threaded, richtig?
Multi-Prozess.
Also du hast eine Aufgabe und der sorgt dafür, dass es parallel stattfindet, wenn du willst, ohne dass du dich jetzt doll groß kümmern müsstest.
Genau. Also Erlang ist ein bisschen wie so ein kleines Unix. Du hast ja so ein eigenes OS. Du hast Prozesse und du hast die Kommunikation zwischen den Prozessen. Das ist alles Teil der Sprache. Das sagt man dann immer wieder, dass einfach bestimmte Dinge da einfach mal mega performant sind. Und die Syntax ist halt anders. Was mir jetzt interessieren würde, zum Lernen wäre Skala, würde ich mir glaube ich als nächstes anschauen wollen. Du hast noch keine guten Vorsätze.
Nee, nee, nee.
Also ich, was ich bisher sträflich vernachlässigt habe, sind diese ganzen Infrastruktursachen wie Heroku und so. Also dieses Cloudzeug. Also ich mache ja sowas nicht so. Also ich lerne eigentlich keine Sprachen, um jetzt meine Sprache gelernt zu haben, sondern weil ich ein konkretes Ziel damit erreichen will. Und habe so das Gefühl, dass so dieses mal eben eine VM aufsetzen für ein kleines Geld. Und wenn sie abhebt, dann muss man ein bisschen mehr zahlen, aber muss ich halt trotzdem nicht um die Skalierbarkeit Gedanken machen. Ist sowas, was mir in meinem Toolkit noch sträflich fehlt. Da ist was dran.
Das fehlt mir auch sträflich.
Und da scheinen ja mittlerweile, gerade von Horoku her, ich habe immer wieder bei FS Horoku. Das ist nicht mehr nur für Rails. Du kannst da jeden beliebigen Prozess hochscheuchen mittlerweile. Also wenn du deinen Node Server irgendwo in der Cloud haben willst, dann sagst du ihnen Bescheid und dann fahren die für dich ein Node hoch. Und ja, wie gesagt, kenne ich mich bisher null mit aus, aber klingt alles ganz, ganz schön spannend.
So Leute, das wird jetzt sowieso eine kürzere Sendung. Ein oder zwei Themen machen wir noch, oder? Du hast ja noch was notiert. Max hatte noch was vorhin gelassen. Siri Proxy hast du gesagt. Ich weiß nicht genau, was du damit meinst, aber du kannst es mir ja mal erklären.
Siri Proxy ist so ein Tool, mit dem man, also es gibt ja einige Versuche, wie man Siri aufbohren kann. Apple bietet bisher noch keine API dafür. Und jetzt sind ein paar schlaue Hacker auf die Idee gekommen, da ein Proxy dazwischen zu schalten. Und zwar zwischen den Apple Server und das Telefon, das iPhone. Das macht man im Wesentlichen, man braucht einen eigenen DNS Server, auf dem man die entsprechende Domain umbiegt, mit der sich Siri verbinden möchte. Man braucht den Proxy. Und da das ganze SSL verschlüsselt ist, muss man noch ein eigenes Zertifikat auf dem iPhone installieren. Also man braucht keinen Jailbreak dafür und kann damit Siri zum Laufen bringen. Und da gibt es, wie das genau funktioniert, habe ich mir bisher auch nicht genauer angeguckt. Meine Vermutung ist, dass sozusagen der Traffic zu Apple, also die Spracherkennung, wird durchgelassen. Und dann wird das erkannte Wort wieder zurückgeschickt. Und dann kannst du halt darauf irgendwelche Befehle aufbauen. Und ja, da gibt es dann so ein paar Leute, die darüber ihren Media Center steuern, in dem sie mit die sagen, du spiel mal das und das ab, spiel mal die letzte, das oder die ihrem Auto Bescheid sagen, mach mal Motor an. Oder mach das Auto den Motor an, fahr nach links, dann fährt es gegen die Wand oder weiß der Teufel was. Ja, das macht auf jeden Fall den Eindruck, als ob da noch ein bisschen was kommen könnte, durchaus. Also ich hoffe mal, dass es Apple dazu bewegt, die APs schneller zu entwickeln, weil sollte natürlich eigentlich so sein, dass man sowas über App steuern kann, aber ja, das klingt ganz spannend, fand ich so.
Ich hab's jetzt nicht so ganz verstanden, muss man das jetzt, geht das jetzt nur mit Jailbreak oder?
Nee, nee, du brauchst keinen Jailbreak, du brauchst halt ein Rechner irgendwo, also ist quasi ein Man in the Middle. Nicht Attack.
Aber macht Siri nicht irgendwie HTTPS?
Ja, genau, darum brauchst du ja ein eigenes, darum brauchst du ja noch ein Zertifikat installieren.
Ah, und dann frisst er das schon.
Dann frisst er das schon, genau. Da braucht man keinen Jailbreak für zu machen. Ist zum einen eine Möglichkeit, um auf alten iPhones Siri nachzurüsten, wem du diesen Siri-Proxy nimmst, aber du kannst halt, wenn du einmal drin bist in der Kommunikation, dann kannst du abfangen, was du willst, dann kannst du da ein Skript dazwischen hängen.
Klingt so wie etwas, was im nächsten Dot-Dot-Release nicht mehr funktioniert.
Also ich meine, eigene Zertifikate installieren muss auch weiterhin gehen, können sehr nicht wahnsinnig viel gegen machen. Und auf die restliche, also wenn DNS-Zack irgendwann mal kommt, dann sind sie natürlich außen vor. Aber bis dahin wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was da großartig passieren soll. Und ich wüsste auch nicht, was sie jetzt großartig dagegen haben sollen, weil ich meine, wer wird sich schon jetzt mit Fehlaufwand hier so einen eigenen DNS-Server und eigener Proxy-Server und sowas, das ist ja schon, das macht ja nicht jeder und haben sie auch keinen Nachteil von.
Na gut, könnten natürlich dann auch irgendwie nochmal so eine eigene Krypto einbauen, um so im Endeffekt eben auszuschließen. Das scheinen sie ja wohl derzeit noch nicht getan zu haben. Zumindest explizit eben genau dieses Zertifikat da auch irgendwie, aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch zu wackelig.
Ja. Also ich hoffe mal, dass das offen bleibt.
Aber ein schönes Experiment.
Ja, kann man auf jeden Fall.
Und noch zu Siri noch?
Immer noch, nur um meinen Thema zu stellen. Also es ist so, immer noch sehr wenig, ja.
Warum?
Weil zum einen die Sachen, die ich so an meinem Telefon mache, mit Siri im Augenblick nicht gehen. Also was mache ich den ganzen Tag, weil ich lese irgendwelche Artikel.
Suchst du was?
Zum Suchen eigentlich schon. Das ist sehr praktisch gewesen. Da habe ich im Bett gelegen und irgendwie so, das Schlafzimmer war sehr kalt, weil frisch gelüftet. Man wollte die Decke nicht unbedingt vornehmen und so. Und dann hier so irgendwie auf dem Rücken liegen tippen. Und dann konnte man da mit Wikipedia absurfen. Das ging sehr gut. Nicht, was ihr wieder denkt.
Siri, deck nicht zu. Siri, dreh die Heizung auf. Habt ihr denn eigentlich von diesem komischen Thermostat-Teil?
Stimmt, wie ist das?
Nest. Habt ihr euch das mal genauer angeschaut?
Klar.
Ich wär zurecht nicht schlau draus.
Wie? Was hast du da nicht schlau draus?
Naja, ich seh immer nur dieses Thermostat.
Ja, weiter?
Ja, aber was steuert dieses Thermostat?
Na, deine Heizung. Du hast ja auch so ein Ding da an der Wand.
Ja, aber wie?
Na, wie steuert denn dein Teil da das?
Na, das ist ein Kabel. Das geht nach hinten und spricht mit ihm das proprietary Protokoll.
Ist da doch auch so.
Ein Kabel. Das Ding macht irgendwie WLAN.
Also du kannst auch, ja. Aber das, also du kannst ja, wenn du, also es gibt in Europa nicht, also ihr braucht gar nicht gucken, ob es jetzt für euch gibt. Das gibt es hier noch nicht in Europa. Wenn du bei diesem Nest, du kannst schon mal den Link irgendwie posten oder dir merken. Wenn man sich das kauft oder kaufen will, kann man da auf so einer Webseite klicken, welche Kabel sozusagen das alte Gerät hat. Also du hast ja so eine Anschlussleiste.
Wo denn? In diesem Store oder was?
Also da gibt es irgendwo so eine Seite, wo man klicken kann, ob das Nest für einen kompatibel ist. Und da kann man die ganzen verschiedenen Kabelnamen anklicken, die bei dem eigenen Gerät, was man schon hat, die da so sind. Und dann klickt man die an und dann sagen die einem, ob das Nest-Ding damit klarkommt oder nicht. Und ja, also es läuft ganz normal, wie das, was man vorher hatte, auch nur halt ein bisschen cooler.
Ja gut, aber das hilft mir ja nicht weiter, weil in meiner Wohnung ist es so, dass ich halt nur einen Thermostat habe und es gibt sozusagen nur eine einzige Referenz und eine einzige Steuerung und die ist halt zentral direkt an der Heizung.
Na, ich glaube genauso ist das ja auch gedacht.
Ja, aber das hilft einem ja nie weiter.
Wie meinst du dieses direkt an der Heizung? Also das ist doch hier an der neben der Tür dieses Teil, was ich da sehe. Das ist doch das, was genau so ein Nest ersetzen würde.
Genau, da läuft ein Kabel hinten zu der Box, da wo das Wasser heiß gemacht wird.
Korrekt. Ja, und dann nimmst du das da ab. Da sind da zwei, drei Kabel und dann steckst du diese zwei, drei Kabel, wenn das Nest mit dem Ding kompatibel ist, in das Nest-Ding rein und dann übernimmt das Nest das Gerät, was wir da sehen.
Ja gut, dann tut das Ding exakt genau das gleiche wie das jetzt.
Nur bunt. Ja, und in schlauer.
In schlauer, ja.
Und in fernsteuerbar. Und der merkt sich halt, also der kommt schon mit so einer gewissen Eigenintelligenz.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass du halt nach wie vor nur einen einzigen Ort hast, an dem du misst und auch nur einen einzigen, an dem du regeln. Das heißt, du machst das global für deine gesamte Wohnung.
Es gibt ja viele Wohnungen, die haben dann mehrere von diesen Dingern. Wie soll das sonst auch gehen mit der Steuerung?
Ja, aber mehrere in der Wohnung helfen dir nicht, wenn du nur eine einzige Stelle hast, wo Wasser an Wasser ausgeht und alle Heizungen fest eingestellt sind. Die einzige Lösung, mit der das geht, ist, dass du die Steuerung an der Heizung hast.
Ja, aber das ist doch anscheinend langsam vorbei.
So was kannst du bei Konrad kaufen. Gibt es fertig als Funkteile. Dann hast du für dich für jeden Raum einen Thermostat. Und für jede Heizung in deinem Raum ein per Funk regelbare...
Thermostat.
Nein, das ist ja kein Thermostat. Das ist einfach ein Öffner quasi für die Heizung. Also ein Durchflussregler, der halt fernsteuerbar ist und der von dem Thermostat gesagt bekommt, ob er sich jetzt zuschalten soll oder nicht. Weil ich will ja nicht global für meine ganze Wohnung die Temperatur regeln. Ich will zum Beispiel sagen können, was weiß ich, nachts sind für mich überhaupt nur zwei Räume relevant. Nämlich da, wo irgendwie geschlafen wird, und da hätte ich gerne diese Temperatur und vielleicht in der Küche noch irgendwie eine gewisse Temperatur vorhalten und der Rest kann meinetwegen auf irgendwas Entspanntes abkühlen. Und tagsüber sind dann die Schlafzimmer nicht so interessant und du willst die anderen Zimmer warm haben.
Ich verstehe das ja auch nicht, warum diese Dinge an der Wand sich so durchgesetzt haben. Also ich habe in meiner Wohnung auch noch an jeder Heizung halt so einen Drehthermostater irgendwie. Und finde das auch ganz cool, weil in der Küche irgendwie so kann es gleich ausbleiben, ist mir Schnuppe, da kann es kalt sein, da ist eben ein Kühlschrank. Und Schlafzimmer ist auch nicht so wichtig, da schlaf ich, da will ich gar nicht so warm haben.
Die kannst du halt nicht zeitregeln. Ich hab hier zum Beispiel Zeitregeln drin. Ich hab das hier, wenn ich, also, jetzt hab ich es halt angeschaltet, weil jetzt wird hier spät gefunkt, aber normalerweise bin ich halt abends nicht da, bzw. um 17 Uhr bin ich hier allerspätestens raus. So hab ich das Ding halt programmiert, dass eben in meinen Nicht-Büro-Zeiten, Nicht-Studio-Zeiten fährt er halt auf so, was weiß ich, 15 Grad runter. Und morgens geht er halt um neun los und fängt an hier zu heizen, sodass wenn ich hier irgendwie reinkomme, zu den üblichen Zeiten, ist eben einfach schon angenehme Temperatur. Das ist halt eigentlich ganz cool. Und bloß in der größeren Wohnung will man da einfach ein abgestimmtes System haben, was eben jeden Raum einzeln regeln kann und dann eben die Heizung so intelligent steuert, dass er eben weiß, ah, in dem Raum, in dem Raum, in dem Raum muss jetzt geheizt werden, liefer mal heißes Wasser. Also wenn du jetzt so eine Etagenheizung hast, also wenn du quasi auch komplett das heiße Wasser produzierst für deine Wohnung, wenn du Zentrale hast.
Ich glaube, die Amis haben da wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen anderes Empfinden. Ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt ein oder mehrere so eine Dinge haben, aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, die machen entweder die ganze Wohnung oder gar nicht, also weißt schon.
Aber die reden auch davon, dass sie irgendwie Kosten sparen wollen.
Ja, Kosten sparen heißt erstmal, dass sie halt die gesamte Wohnung dann ein bisschen weniger heizen. Aber die haben das noch nicht so pro Raum vielleicht. Ich weiß es nicht, also ich habe jetzt da gar nicht geguckt, ob die da auch mehr, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, das Ding kostet 250 Dollar, dass sie sich dann für jeden Raum so ein Ding holen. Und ob das dann überhaupt geht, also die haben ja eben wahrscheinlich nicht einen Regler pro, obwohl doch, die haben wahrscheinlich pro Raum sowieso ihre Aircondition mit dran und so weiter, richtig?
Ich kann dir jetzt nicht so viel sagen über den Wohn- und Lifestyle der Vereinigten Staaten von A.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie ein schönes Video gedreht.
Jaja, es ist alles so ganz, ganz, sieht so nice aus und so.
Der ehemalige iPod, was war der? Marketing-Typ oder? Inventor?
Nö, der war sogar für die Hardware irgendwie zuständig.
Also ich bin da mal sehr gespannt drauf, was die ersten Testberichte von dem Ding sagen. Weil so, ich meine, dieses Video ist natürlich so, ha, ja, deine Heizung und automatisch und viel Energie sparen und... Ach, kann ich noch, ich war noch auf der TEDx, davon kann ich ja noch ein bisschen erzählen.
Also was ich auf jeden Fall richtig finde ist, Haushaltsgeräte und so weiter auch mal mit schlauer machen und intelligent und irgendwie steuerbar machen und so. Nichts hätte ich lieber als eine iPhone App, mit der ich wirklich die Temperatur in meiner Wohnung steuern kann. Ja, wo man sich einfach auf so einen zentralen Rechner...
Find my friends würde ich meiner Wohnung schon erlauben, dass sie wissen darf, wo ich gerade bin.
Oh, das wäre natürlich schön. Das ist natürlich eine geile Idee.
Naja, also ich meine, was, also klar, du kannst jetzt einstellen, ich komme immer um 17 Uhr nach Hause, dann gehst du mal einen Abend saufen und dann heizt sie da zu Tode deine Bude und du bist gar nicht da, oder? Du bist irgendwie krank, dir ist nicht so gut auf Arbeit, du fährst drei Stunden früher nach Hause und dann kommst du nach Hause und dann bist du gleich noch viel kränker, weil es ist immer noch arschkalt. Und mit Find my friends merkst du, oh, der kommt langsam näher und eigentlich ist er noch arbeiten. Das heißt, wenn er näher kommt, dann kommt er wohl gleich. Ich heiz schon mal los. Das ist eine geile Idee. Eigentlich ist alles schon da.
Dann kann man ja auch irgendwie auf den Hals mal vor button drücken.
Da brauchst du doch gar nicht, das merkst du noch, wenn du dich näherst. Also ich meine, wie lange braucht dir denn, bis so heiß ist?
Das kann ganz schön teuer werden, wenn das Ding immer wieder von einer total niedrigen Temperatur auf eine Wunschtemperatur hochheizt. Das ist dann unter Umständen deutlich höherer Verbrauch, als wenn du die ganze Zeit versuchst, einen gewissen Level zu halten.
Wieso, wenn die merkt, du bewegst dich jetzt langsam in Richtung nach Hause?
Das sollte aber auch Teil des Spiels sein. So ein Ding darf eigentlich nicht nur die Temperatur regeln, sondern es muss eigentlich auch den Verbrauch in irgendeiner Form mitrechnen können. Und selber herausfinden, was Sache ist. Es muss zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, Gasverbrauch, Stromverbrauch, was auch immer in dem Moment entscheidend ist, separat abgreifen können.
Vor allem, man muss ja auch nicht gleich volle Pulle heizen, wenn du dich nach Hause näherst, sondern dann kann man merken, ok, er könnte kommen, wir erhöhen schon mal um zwei, drei Grad damit, wenn er wirklich nach Hause kommt, dass nicht eine Stunde der Autos warm ist, sondern nur noch eine halbe.
Du könntest ja auch so machen, wie die Autos das machen, Dennis. Du könntest ja so einen so einen beheizbaren Overall nehmen. Weißt du, dass wenn du reinkommst und es ist noch kalt, dass du diesen Overall anziehst und dann so wie eine Heizdecke, so eine belaufbare Heizdecke.
Du meinst, weil Autos mit den Sitzheizungen oder wie?
Jaja, klar. Ich meine, du setzt dich ins kalte Auto rein, machst die Sitzheizung an, irgendwie nach zehn Sekunden nass zu missen, heisst ein Arsch. Das hilft schon mal.
Also zum Beispiel ich mach so, was ich mache, schalt mein Telefon nachts in Flugmodus. Das ist so eine Sensorik, die relativ einfach abgreifbar ist. Ja klar, weil das ist das einzige...
Du machst jedes... Du machst vor dem Schlafen, geh das aus?
Da hat mich meine Freundin zu genötigt, weil ja, einfach aus dem Grund, weil...
Silent Taste?
Ja, dann vibriert es aber noch. Ich hab's so eingestellt, dass es dann auch vibriert.
Dann lass doch die Scheiße im Wohnzimmer liegen.
Telefon im Wohnzimmer liegen lassen?
Ja, ausmachen.
Ausmachen? Ob es im Wohnzimmer liegt oder ob es aus ist... Dann brauchst du nicht jeden Morgen ein- und auszuschalten, weil ich einfach mache Airplane-Modus an und wieder aus.
Was heißt das, so im Sinne von auch keinen WLAN mehr?
Dann hab ich keinen WLAN. Nee, das ist halt keine Kommunikation mehr. Ich bin nicht mehr erreichbar.
So, Punkt.
Und jetzt kommt kein Twitter mehr durch, jetzt kommt gar nichts mehr durch.
Und surfen in der ganze, also, kannst du auch im Wohnzimmer liegen lassen. Weil wir nutzen das Ganze ja auch nicht mehr wirklich ohne Netz.
Ich kann ja, guck mal, ich lese noch zum Beispiel auf dem iPhone oder nutze es noch, durchaus auch noch im Bett. Und dann, wenn ich sage, alles klar, jetzt macht der Max Bubu, dann drücke ich auf die Airplane-Taste, Airplane-Modus, leg's auf den Nachttisch und da liegt es dann und verbraucht auch nicht ganz so viel Strom. Dann nehm ich's morgens wieder hin, mach einen Airplane-Modus aus und gucke was auf Twitter gibt.
Okay, was wolltest du eigentlich erzählen?
Was ich erzählen wollte, dass das ja eigentlich eine ganz hübsche Sensorik ist, zum Beispiel, wann ich schlafe. Daran könnte so eine Heizung schon mal mitkriegen, wann ich schlafe. Und wenn ich morgens dann das Telefon wieder aus dem Airplane-Modus rausnehme, was ich sowieso jeden Morgen mache.
Aber da gibt's auch diese andere App, die letzte Woche hier Vinny vorgestellt hat, die irgendwie allein schon in deinem Bewegungssensor merkt, dass du schlaf bist.
Ja, sowas hab ich jetzt aber noch nicht. Oder hab's noch gar nicht. Und wer weiß, ob's funktioniert. Aber das ist ja eigentlich, ich wollt nur sagen, wenn es jetzt bei Konrad hier so eine Thermostate gibt, wer auch immer weiß, was diese Scheiße kostet, wahrscheinlich sind die relativ teuer, kann man die irgendwie per W-Lan oder so steuern? Oder wahrscheinlich nur mit irgendeinem dämlichen Funktaster, der nix anschließbar ist, oder?
Ja, die haben dann, ich kenn die nicht so im Detail, aber das ist dann so die eigene Welt, weißt du? Du kannst das dann irgendwie programmieren und musst das auch und Peep-Up-Polen kannst du wahrscheinlich auch viel Zeit mit verbringen und ich hätt halt lieber irgendwie was, was was so ein bisschen klickbar ist und da ab hat.
Klickibunti hier für die Apple Fanboys! Ja, ich meine, das soll ja auch bedienbar sein.
Du kennst doch immer dieses Elend. Ich verzweifle schon an diesem Thermostat. Dieses eine Teil hier im Studio macht mich jedes Mal fertig. Weil ich das einfach nicht verstehe, die Logik, die sie da implementiert haben.
Ich glaube, ich hab noch das nächst kompliziertere Modell. Das ist, äh...
Das ist, wie man so etwas einfaches...
So ein normaler Drehregler an so einem alten Thermostat ist schon eine super Sache. Oder 0,5, irgendwie kann man ganz falsch machen.
Naja, aber ich finde, also ich finde so dieses morgens, bevor ich, also ich fände es ja schon schön, schalte ich ein, bevor ich morgens aufwache. Fahr schon mal, also ich weiß zum Beispiel, dass wenn man die Heizung nicht anmacht, dass dann auch das heiße Wasser bei mir ewig lange braucht, um warm zu werden und so. Soll doch schon mal ein bisschen vorheizen. Macht schon mal das Wasser heiß, damit ich schön in Ruhe duschen kann, ohne jetzt großartig lange zu warten. Zumindest ist ja auch Wasserverschwendung.
Ist das so ein warm Wasser pro Wohnung oder wie?
Na, das läuft über den gleichen Durchlauferhitzer über den, also es ist so eine Gassetagenheizung.
Verstehe, verstehe, aber mir kommt alles irgendwie hier vom Haus schon.
Und die könnte man eigentlich schön steuern über so, ah, der Max hat den Airplay-Modus ausgeschaltet, alles klar, oder jetzt hat er ihn eingeschaltet, jetzt kann man die Temperatur, jetzt schläft er, können wir runterfahren. Was ich unbedingt noch erzählen wollte, weil wir heute so Themen haben, die wahrscheinlich...
Na warte, warte.
Okay.
Wenn wir noch hier bei diesen ganzen Heizen und Strom sind und so, muss ich ja das Thema nochmal kurz irgendwie erwähnen, weil ich finde es immer ein bisschen komisch, was die da so erzählen. Und zwar gibt es doch hier immer diesen versuchten Hype gerade über Smart Meter, ne? Also ich glaube von Google gab es sogar auch mal irgendwie so ein Projekt, oder? Dass du irgendwie dir so einen Stromzähler installieren lässt, der irgendwie einen Netzanschluss hat, also Internetanschluss und dann irgendwie das Stromwerk oder wer auch immer, dann irgendwie das ausliest und du das dann aber selber bei denen dann auf der Webseite lesen kannst, wie viel Strom du verbrauchst. Und also ich finde es ja eigentlich, also Strom selber mitzählen, also ich habe zuhause auch so einen Stromzähler, den man so in die Steckdose steckt und dann da sein Gerät drin, also wo man sich selber drum kümmern muss.
Die taugen oft nicht viel.
Ja doch, also als grobe Richtung kannst du erkennen, wie viel dein Fernseher so im Standby verbraucht, dass der irgendwie, was war es bei mir, 13 Watt verbraucht, obwohl er aus ist sozusagen, bis auf die rote Lampe, dass du ihn einschalten kannst.
Hast einen sehr alten Fernseher.
Oh ja, ich benutze den ja auch nicht. Aber oft ist ja irgendwie die rote Lampe an und du kümmerst dich nicht und der verbraucht aber 13 Watt und dann halt das DVB-T-Gerät dazu auch noch und dann die Antenne und dann bist du bei knapp 50 Watt und du hast noch nicht mal Fernsehen geguckt. Und die Geräte findest du so alle raus und auch lauter anderen Scheiß und kannst das alles ausmachen. Das heißt, zu wissen, wie viel Strom man verbraucht für welches Gerät ist total super. Aber diese Smart Meter, wo sie einem irgendwie suggerieren wollen, dass die ja irgendwann mal den Kühlschrank irgendwie steuern könnten oder dass man irgendwie seine Waschmaschine damit gesteuert kriegt, weil nachts ja eventuell der Strom billiger sein könnte. Das halte ich ja alles für ganz schön großen Blödsinn und da glaube ich ja noch nicht so dran. Ich glaube, da wird man eher noch mehr abgezockt, weil sie wissen, wie der Bedarf irgendwie ist und ich, ja, nee. Du kannst auch nachts deine Waschmaschine nicht anwerfen, dann kommt meine Nachbarin runter und fragt mir, ob ich einen Knall habe. Also wie gesagt, Strom messen, voll super, kann man sich für 10 Euro so eine kleinen Dinger kaufen, die sind vielleicht nicht voll super, reichen aber total aus, um zu wissen, ob irgendwelche Geräte, wie viel Strom sie so ziehen, ob es Sinn macht, die rauszuziehen über Nacht oder nicht oder wann auch immer man die so benutzt oder ob es egal ist und man die drin lassen kann. Also zum Beispiel so eine Apple-Express-Station kostet, verbraucht irgendwie 2 Watt oder so, da ist es wirklich Schnuppe. Aber bei so anderen Sachen, die noch weniger machen als meine Express und dann irgendwie 15 Watt verbrauchen, das geht mal gar nicht.
Gute Indikatoren sind auch Katzen.
Weil die sich dahinsetzen, weil da warm ist.
Wenn sich die Katze draufsetzt, dann verbraucht das Gerät zu viel Strom. Ist tatsächlich so, ich habe meinen ersten Apple-TV, den habe ich unter anderem deswegen dann angefangen, rauszuziehen, weil sich die Katze immer drauf gesetzt hat und so wohlig geworden ist. Und dann habe ich auch mal drauf gefasst und so nee, das will man nicht.
Das ist ja totale Katzentoaster, ne? Der Chat weiß mal wieder alles besser und verweist uns hier auf eine Ab- und die staune gerade ein bisschen F-H-E-Mobile. Etwas strange Design und etwas strange Icon, aber...
Hoch-Runter-Buttons, die einfach gedrehten, was sind das?
Deutsches Design at its best, aber wir ignorieren das jetzt mal einfach und schauen mal, das hier ist nämlich tatsächlich das, was ich gerade haben wollte, nämlich eine iPhone ab zur Steuerung eines F-H-E-M-basierten Hausautomations-Servers, womit sämtliche FS-20-Geräte gesteuert werden können.
Und was hast du hier für ein Gerät?
Außerdem werden die Messwerte von HMS-Temperatursensoren wie dem HMS-100TF und dem HMS-100T und FHT-Heizungssteuerung erfasst.
Oh, na dann ist ja alles gut.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon hier die Rede ist, aber offensichtlich handelt es sich hier um bestimmte Standards, die wahrscheinlich einschlägig...
Mit denen noch ein bisschen letzten Winkel irgendwie.
Genau so der Nerd von heute hat wahrscheinlich die Begriffe normalerweise schon total parat.
Wie heißt die Seite? Bytefeet. So, nachdem wir jetzt gerade auf nest.com für den total schönen Thermostat waren, gehen wir jetzt hier auf das, was wirklich benutzt. Was wirklich, was du alles einstellen kannst, was aber aussieht, als ob man sich jedes Mal übers iPhone ergießen möchte. Unsere iPhone-Hits.
Gipfel-Server vor Haus-Automation. Aha, guck an.
Ja, na mach mal. Brauchst du einen eigenen Server dafür?
Fritzbox zum Beispiel.
Ach, ach.
Apple-Interpreter.
Ach, man kann seine Fritzbox aufmachen, dann kann man darüber das Ding steuern. Das ist natürlich eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, aber die Hardware, was ist die Hardware? Über Serial Port oder was? Verstehe.
Serial Port, haben die Fritzbox einen Serial Port?
Supported Hardware.
Ja, anscheinend.
Cool Kuhn FS20, also FS20 ist ein Protokoll. Oh Gott, das ist ja wirklich eine Schlacht von Abkürzungen und Begriffen.
Das sind halt die Hacker, die gehen die Sache voran und irgendwann übernimmt sie eine große Bude, so wie dieses Nest.
Ja klar, ich vermute, ja gut, aber das ist wahrscheinlich hier einfach so eine Reihe von allen möglichen Sensorprotokollen und Protokollen zur Steuerung von irgendwelchen Schaltern. Hier rolle ich den hoch, rolle ich den runter, etc. Heizung an und aus. Und mir ist aber jetzt auch noch nicht so ganz klar, was jetzt hier eigentlich die Hardware ist. Also beziehungsweise wie an diese Hardware herangegangen wird. Das sollten wir einfach mal den Tetris scrollen lassen.
Ach Gott, es gibt tatsächlich für eine Fritzbox 7390, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, welche ich habe. Ich glaube, ich habe die 7290. Gibt es eine Hardware, eine Laborversion, die so ein FHEM Server von vornherein eingebaut hat? Sieht ihr, dafür ist eine Fritzbox gut.
Na das ist doch super, dann könnte man die mal wirklich für irgendwas produktiv benutzen.
Endlich mal.
Ach guck an, Labor.
Die haben immer so Laborversion.
Ist das einfach nur eine andere Firmware?
Genau.
Firmware bleibt gleich. Ja, aber was ist die Hardware? Also ich meine, wie geht das dann über Ethernet? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Hm, unklar. Wir verweisen mal hier einfach auf diese Software und packen das hier schön in die Links und die Shownotes. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein schönes Thema. Der Winter steht vor der Tür und FHE, was war das? Wie ist dieses Tool?
So, ich hab nochmal ein Thema, was schön ist.
Ja.
Und zwar habt ihr diese Lytro-Kamera mitbekommen? lytro.com Dieses quadratische Teil, was so... Genau, das ist eine Light Field Camera.
Achso, wo man später scharf stellt.
Genau, die unfokussiert fotografiert. Und ich hab dabei hier AllThingsD, die machen ja immer diese... Diese Konferenz. Und die haben... Da haben sie das auf der Bühne vorgeführt und haben sich mit dem Entwickler oder mit dem CEO der Firma, die das herstellt, unterhalten. Und das macht echt einen sehr, sehr coolen Eindruck. Also es ist... Die haben eine Kamera, wenn ich das richtig sehe, mit total vielen kleinen Mikro-Linsen. Also sie haben nicht nur eine Linse, sondern quasi hunderte. Und damit können sie ein Bild aufnehmen, was man im Nachhinein scharf stellen kann. Was ich sehr krass finde.
Also nicht im Nachhinein scharf stellen, sondern wenn du drei Objekte hast, eins hinten, eins in der Mitte, eins vorne, dann kannst du später sowohl das hintere oder das mittlere oder das vordere scharf stellen.
Du kannst jeden beliebigen Punkt scharf stellen.
Genau.
Und das ist, die haben ja oben auf der Website so eine Picture Gallery, wo man so ein paar Beispielbilder sich angucken kann.
Aber die machen das doch schon mit so einem Berechnungsvoodoo, oder?
Was ist das hier ohne Flash? Ich hab keinen Flash und er sagt mir, ich soll in Adobe Flash play. To experience this living picture.
Stimmt, ist Flash. Ja, hm, schade. Dann hat er es geschafft, meinen Click-to-Flash irgendwie auszurichten.
Du hast doch schon einmal gesagt erlauben, weil du da so oft warst.
Auf jeden Fall sieht das extrem schick aus, wenn man da, also man kann da so wirklich auf so Fotos rumklicken und kann jede beliebige Stelle im Nachhinein scharf stellen. Das ist schon sehr, sehr cool. Und kostet irgendwie, also sie wollen die jetzt verkaufen demnächst. Die ist extrem klein, also sie sieht auf den Bildern ziemlich groß aus.
Das heißt, das Teil gibt es noch gar nicht.
Das ist, das kommt jetzt. Was kostet es?
I want one.
Das ist doch so eine Weihnachtsgeschenkidee, oder?
Ja, das ist bestimmt wieder wie diese Tastatur, wo jede Tastatur in einem Bildschirm ist. Wie ist dieses Teil noch gleich? Diese Tastatur wohl so.
Ja, ich weiß welche du meinst von diesen Design. Opti, oh nee.
Optimus oder so was. Das Ding kam dann einfach nie.
Doch, doch, das kam.
Wie, das kam?
Die kannst du kaufen. Die ist, also konntest du zumindest, die gab's. Wir haben ja Produkte verkauft. Das war natürlich unglaublich teuer, weil wirklich in jeder Taste eine LED-Tastatur, einen LED-Bildschirm drinnen steckte. Und dann gab's zuerst eine Variante, wo du nur so sechs Tasten hattest, die du mit LEDs beliebig belegen konntest. Und dann haben sie irgendwann angefangen, so die Tastatur Gesundheit. Dann hattest du irgendwann die Möglichkeit, dir quasi so eine Tastatur zu kaufen, ohne diese LEDs drauf, und dann nach und nach LEDs zuzukaufen, für ein bisschen Geld.
Aber dann krieg ich zu Weihnachten wieder eine neue LED-Taste.
Genau, so was. Und dann irgendwann nach 130 Jahren hast du deine Tastatur voll.
OLED, genau.
Wobei, Art Lebedev, genau, das war so eine Optimus-SD.
Dabei wollte ich doch niesen.
Na gut, ist doch schön, wenn es das...
Und es gab aber von irgendeinem anderen Hersteller gab es noch so was Ähnliches. Die sind aber ein bisschen einfacher vorgegangen, und zwar haben die einfach ein großes LCD-Display genommen und haben dann eine weitgehend transparente Tastatur da oben drüber gelegt. Der Effekt ist natürlich sehr, sehr ähnlich und du brauchst nicht diese hunderten von Tasten, was das ganze dramatisch billiger macht. Aber sie haben sogar eine Mac-Software und alles und... Wobei, was soll man mit sowas auch? Ihr habt sie ja wohl nicht mehr alle.
Jetzt hab ich schon aufgefallen, dass noch keiner so richtig über das iPad 3 redet.
Doch, doch, so ein bisschen, es kommt doch jetzt langsam.
Ja, die haben jetzt alle Angst, weil sie beim iPhone 4S irgendwie mit ihren iPhone 5-Metall-Rückseite, 4-Zoll-Shit und weiss nicht, was sie alles erzählt haben, so voll daneben lagen. Deswegen traut es jetzt keiner mehr.
Aber wir lagen gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir haben uns ja glaube ich auch ein bisschen verleiten lassen, aber irgendwann glaube ich, meint ich doch auch, wir haben Spaß. Wahrscheinlich heißt es einfach nur 4S oder war da nicht mal irgendwann was?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob du das so gesagt hast, aber auf jeden Fall waren wir uns eigentlich einig, dass das Ding an sich so ganz okay ist und uns jetzt nicht so viel einfallen würde, was man da jetzt an der Hardware noch groß machen könnte. Und kam es ja dann eigentlich auch, außer schneller.
Ein bisschen schneller, ein bisschen mehr RAM speichert, ralala, irgendwas, aber...
Mehr RAM hat es glaube ich...
Hat es noch nicht mal, genau. Ach, schnellerer RAM.
Der Prozess hat sich sogar langsamer geworden.
Ich frage mich ja, ob sie es schaffen, dieses iPad so zu machen, dass...
Also Retina wäre schon ein cooler Schritt. Wieso, kannst du mit dem iPad nichts anfangen?
Nö, eigentlich nicht.
Ist das jetzt was da oben an der Wand klebt, wo ab und zu mal irgendwie so eine Nachricht kommt?
Ich hab eins, was ich immer dabei hab. Das teste ich sozusagen on the road. Das andere ist hier so für den Studie-Einsatz gedacht.
Beides einser?
Ja, aber beim Zweier sag ich nun überhaupt gar keinen Punkt für mich.
Und du brauchst es nicht, weil du MacBook Air hast, richtig?
Ja, ich kann gut arbeiten mit Computern. Das ging schon lange besser. Und von daher wüsste ich jetzt nicht so richtig, was mir ein iPad bietet. Also ich hab's zum Buchlesen benutzt. Wobei da hätte ich halt dann doch gerne mal eine höhere Auflösung.
Und ein bisschen leichter wegen Festhalten. Was ja mit dem Zweier dann gekommen ist. Also iPad 3 war es wahrscheinlich richtig cool. Ich hab ja auch keins, weil ich sie auch noch nicht so bedarf. Weil ich bin auch so computer-addicted hier. Dass ich da irgendwie ohne Tastatur glaube ich, würde ich auch gar nicht klarkommen. Irgendwie, dass es mir mit dem Tippen und so, wär mir alles viel zu langsam. Auch beim Browsen und so. Ich glaub, das wär mir nix.
Dann find ich Tatzucker besser.
Das Brausen an sich, aber die ganzen Seiten aufrufen. Ich bin ja so ein, ich hab keine Bookmarks, sondern ich hab History. Also wenn ich schon mal irgendwo gewesen bin, dann ist es ja in meinen Bookmarks. Also in meiner History, was ja Bookmark ist sozusagen. Und dann tippe ich kurz an und dann kommt alles und dann scroll ich nur noch da hin, wo ich hin will. Also zum Beispiel seit Jahren gucke ich mir die Comits von FreeBSD an und dann tippe ich nur LE ein und dann kommt lists.freebsd.com, weil das so Listen sind, so heißt das Server halt. Und dann hab ich da meine drei Zeilen und dann wähle ich die aus. Weil jetzt in Bookmarks stundenlang irgendwie die Links zu suchen, das dauert mir auch alles viel zu lange. Deswegen, das muss so Spotlight-mäßig, ich surfe so Spotlight-mäßig, tippe kurz an, was ich will und dann...
Das geht auf dem iPad. Ich bin großer Freund des iPads. Ich nutze das zu Hause. Wie gesagt, ich nutze... Ich glaube, hatten wir am letzten Mal schon das Thema. Zum Coden nutze ich den Mac. Und es gibt so ein paar komplexere Sachen. Dafür nehme ich dann auch. Also wenn ich eine Shell brauche, dann kommt man nicht drum rum. Aber auch wenn man sich mit einem PS5, mit einem Server verbindet und so diese ganzen Späße. Aber zum Lesen, also Reader ist mein Zuhause, mein zweites quasi. Flipboard nutze ich sehr gerne. Es ist so dieses Leseteil, wo man so seine ganzen Feeds, seine ganzen Facebook und Twitter und weißer Teufel, was Feeds reinpullen kann und dann werden die da irgendwie ein bisschen hübsch aufgearbeitet. Nutze ich sehr gerne. Instapaper bzw. Read it later. Nutze ich beides nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Auch zum Lesen. Spiele finde ich auf dem iPad tausendmal besser als auf dem iPhone, wegen größeren Display. Und surfen, recherchieren, irgendwas raussuchen, Mails lesen, Twitter lesen.
Ja, Mail lesen geht ganz gut.
Mache ich wirklich alles, wo man halt nicht so viel tippen muss, oder?
Ja, weil Mail lesen ist für mich in dem Moment auch schon wieder vorbei auf dem iPad, wenn da nur ein Attachment ist, was ich abspeichern muss. Also das stellt mich überhaupt am meisten. Ich kann nicht mit Dateien arbeiten. Ich kann überhaupt, bin nicht in der Lage, Daten von dem einen Programm in das andere Programm weiter zu leiten. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Ich kann das nicht organisieren, ich kann das nicht wegstrukturieren. Ich kriege Mails, da ist ein, keine Ahnung, ich kriege eine Mail mit einer Rechnung, das muss in den Ordner mit den Rechnungen von der Firma, la la la. Die Telekom-Rechnungen in den Ordner und so.
Aber das würde ich sagen, sowas bleibt bei mir in einer Mail drin, kommt da ein Rechnungsordner in die Mail.
Spiegel hat das neue Intro von dem David zugeschickt fürs nächste Mobile Mac, das muss in den Mobile Macs nächste Sendung Planungsordner rein, zack, bumm, auf Dropbox und dann sync das und so weiter. Das sind so die Sachen, die ich permanent tue und da hilft mir dann ein iPad einfach nie weiter, weil ich kann in dem Mail-Programm nichts in meine Dropbox ablegen, das geht einfach nicht. Das ist einfach nicht vorgesehen. Und das steht auch total in den Sternen, wann das jemals überhaupt möglich sein wird, eher gar nicht.
Das iPad ist wahrscheinlich schon auch mehr so ein Konsumergerät und gar nicht.
Also es gibt eine Möglichkeit, Dateien zwischen Apps auszutauschen. Die ist halt relativ unterentwickelt.
Das hast du schön gesagt. Aber... Das ist unbrauchbar. Weil ich kann nur Dateien eines bestimmten Typs, Programme, die der Meinung sind, so. Aber ich kann nicht irgendwas kriegen und es irgendwo hin tun. Und das kann ich halt auf dem Mac. Ja, ich kann ja irgendeinen Binary Blob kriegen und den will ich in irgendeinen Ordner tun. Das geht aber nicht auf dem iPad. Es gibt keinerlei Möglichkeiten, irgendwas zu kanalisieren. Ich kann auch nichts organisieren. Außerdem lebt immer alles nur in seiner eigenen Wolke. Also alles lebt immer nur in seinem eigenen Programm. Und wenn ich es dann von dem einen Programm ins andere mache, dann kopiere ich es. Das ist ja nicht so, dass ich die Datei weiterleite, sondern ich lege dann, was weiß ich, von dem PDF noch eine Kopie in iBooks an und dann vielleicht noch in Goodreader auch noch eine Kopie. Und dann liegt diese Datei 3-, 4-, 5-mal auf meinem iPad nur rum, damit jedes Programm anzeigen könnte, mit dem ich es gerade bräuchte.
Für Dateien ist es, dafür ist es nicht gedacht. Das ist auch nicht der Einsatzzweck, aber für alles, wo man keine Dateien für braucht.
Das ist für Couchsurfing.
Ja, dafür ist es auch ganz nett, aber ich sitze halt selten auf der Couch.
Also ich würde sagen beim iPad 3, weil darum ging es ja, ne? Retina-Verdoppelung hätten wir gerne.
Genau, dann könnte man das Ding vielleicht als Lesegerät gut benutzen.
Und ich glaube, nochmal irgendwie 50 Gramm weggespart oder wie viel auch immer, könnte nicht schaden. Ich weiß nicht, es schafft man wahrscheinlich nicht, aber das wäre so ganz cool. Schnell genug, also...
Also vom Gewicht her finde ich, stört mich nicht. Habe ich jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass es mir irgendwie zu schwer wäre oder sowas. Also ich finde es da sehr angenehm. Und ja, Retina, klar, kann man sich immer leicht vorstellen. Wäre schöner. Ich würde ja eher darauf hoffen, dass ich dann wieder ein bisschen mehr in die Software-Richtung denke. Was ich mal vermute, dass sie das auch über kurz oder lang vorhaben. Da muss sich halt dieses iOS langsam entwickeln. Und da finde ich halt sowohl von Android, wie heißen sie da? Intents. Bei Windows 8 soll es Contracts heißen. Also dieses, hey, ich hab hier diese Daten. Sag mir mal, wer damit was anfangen kann. Und so ein Mechanismus in Schöner fände ich geil. Also seien es die Services oder sowas. Ob jetzt da eine App die Datei hat oder mehrere Apps, die die Datei hin und her schubsen, ist mir ehrlich gesagt relativ wurscht. Also wenn ich ein Foto rüber schiebe oder sowas, dann ist das okay, wenn das kopiert wird.
Ja, aber es hat alles immer noch keine systemweite Datenbank. Und ich brauch einfach eine systemweite Datenbank. Und diese systemweite Datenbank habe ich halt auf meinem Mac.
Du meinst so ein Feinder oder sowas?
Ein Pfeilsystem halt.
Ja, aber Pfeilsysteme, ich glaube, dass...
Die sind komplex und sie sind schwierig zu benutzen. Aber wenn man weiß, wie es geht und nicht weißet, dann ist es extrem praktisch.
Naja, könnte aber auch besser sein. Also ich finde Pfeilsystem nach wie vor ziemlich krückig.
Ja, sag mir mal was besseres. Was funktioniert besser als das und tut dasselbe?
Das heißt aber nicht, dass man nicht was Besseres bauen sollte.
Ja gut, aber sag mir mal was, was systemweiter ist oder genauso systemweit wie ein Pfeilsystem und sich mindestens genauso gut durchsuchen lässt wie mit Spotlight und wo alle Programme jederzeit darauf zugreifen können.
Also ich finde diesen Zusatz, so wie dieses Dateless, wie das auf dem iPhone oder auf dem iPad der Fall ist. Du hast keine Datei, sondern du hast halt deine App, die hat halt ihre Daten irgendwie vorzuhalten und ich finde den Ansatz schon eigentlich ganz geil. Ich finde das mittlerweile so, das ist eines der schönsten Line-Features wie ich finde. Dieses, wenn ich mal ein Programm beende und dann habe ich da irgendwie in Textedit etwas reingetippt. Jetzt muss ich das speichern, muss mir eine Datei-Namen ausdenken, muss mir überlegen, wo ich das hinpacke. Jetzt ist es so, jetzt geht das zu und nachher geht es wieder auf und ich muss damit nichts zu tun.
Das ist ja immer noch ein Fallsystem.
Natürlich ist da noch ein Fallsystem dahinter, aber in dem Fall ist es dann so dieses Zustandslose. Das ist einfach so.
Ja, aber davon rede ich ja nicht. Ich rede davon, dass der Ort, wo man speichert...
Warum muss ich mir um sowas Gedanken machen?
Weil ich will, dafür benutze ich einen Computer.
Um Datei nirgendwo hinzuspeichern?
Um meine Informationen zu strukturieren. Das ist das, was mein Computer für mich tut. Ich habe Informationen aller Art. Kommunikationsinformationen, Wissen, Daten, Zahlen, Tabellen, Bilder, Designs, das, was ich tue. Audio, Dateien, jeder Podcast, mit dem ich arbeite, wird zwischen zehn Programmen hin und her geworfen, bevor der irgendwie auf dem Server landet. So einen Workflow könnte ich mir auf dem iPad auch nur im Ansatz vorstellen. Vollkommen undenkbar, dass du da solche Utilities zusammenkriegst. Deswegen frage ich mich halt ernsthaft, ab wann so ein iPad für mich überhaupt eine Option sein kann, was sinnvoll ist, damit zu tun.
Was ist denn was Sinnvolles?
Na das, was ich tue, ist sinnvoll.
Na ja, also ich meine, es sind ja nur diverse. Also ich meine, du wirst sicherlich nicht einen Podcast mit dem iPad aufnehmen wollen.
Warum nicht? Wollen würde ich das schon?
Ich glaube, das wird bis dahin ein verdammt weiter Weg sein, falls es jemals so sein soll. Das ist das, was ich sagen würde.
Es sieht aus, als ob das ein verdammt weiter Weg ist.
Da hingegen ein Blogposting zu schreiben, wäre sicherlich sehr unproblematisch. Also ist auf dem iPad sicherlich sehr unproblematisch, wenn man sich ein bisschen...
Nee, das finde ich auch anstrengend. Weil ich einfach nicht Text aus anderen Programmen holen kann. Das ist wieder genau dasselbe Problem. Wenn ich Blogposter, dann hole ich mir Links aus dem Browser, da hole ich mir Bilder aus meinem Fallsystem. Wie das geht, das dauert Tage, bis ich irgendwie da mal link, dann musst du da doppelklick und dann wieder Browser wieder hoch und dann da rein und dann tap und dann nochmal warten und dann copy und dann nochmal doppelklick und dann nochmal wieder rein in das Ding.
Hier Finger ziehst du rüber, bist dann bis zum Safari drinnen.
Auf dem Mac nehme ich die Ural und direkt die da rein. Fertig. Das ist schnell. Auf dem iPad ist das einfach anstrengend.
Das ist nicht zum Content produzieren, das ist zum Content konsumieren.
Ich meine, ich sage ja nicht, dass man mit dem iPad nicht auch Dinge schaffen kann. Das sind andere Sachen, die man damit machen kann und da kommen andere User-Interfaces etc. Das ist nur für mich derzeit noch keine Option und ich frage mich, was wird diesem iPad wohl im nächsten Jahr gegeben werden, was meine Einstellungen unter Umständen ändern?
Dragst du wirklich URLs von einem App in die andere, nicht einfach per Copy-Paste? Dauernd, ganz normal.
Dauernd.
Drag and Drop ist das geilste überhaupt.
Nichts tue ich, glaube ich, mehr den ganzen Tag als irgendwie Dinge hin und her zu drängen.
Mach ich nie.
Und Copy-Paste natürlich auch, aber auch das geht schneller. Weil ich halt, ich kann ja halt hier mit Klack-klack bin ich halt von dem einen Programm ins andere. Beim iPad habe ich Doppelklick-Warten, Wischen.
Also ich meine, mit dem Wischen, das geht nur wirklich schnell.
Nee, ich finde nicht, dass es schnell geht. Es dauert lange. Vor allem, ich habe dann schon wieder vergessen, was ich tun wollte, bis ich wieder zurück bin. Ich kann auch nicht beides. Ich kann auch nicht. Ich sehe ja auch nicht beides gleichzeitig.
Ja, das finde ich zum Beispiel sehr angenehm. Also das finde ich echt extrem angenehm. Darum mag ich auch den Fullscreen-Modus beim Mac OS, beim Byline ganz gerne. Also nicht auf dem 27 Zoll Display, da ist ja totaler Schwachsinn. Aber hier auf dem kleinen Display ist dieser Fullscreen-Modus, weil man wird auch nicht so abgelenkt von anderen Sachen. Und ich finde es auf dem iPad das finde ich echt angenehm. Ich lese irgendwas und wenn ich fertig bin, nehme ich meinen Twitter-Client auf und gucke mal was in Twitter los ist. Und ich habe nicht so dieses, die ganze Zeit, ah, da passiert was und da passiert was und da passiert was, was man ja auf dem Desktop dann doch irgendwie immer hat.
Kurzer Nachtrag noch zu dieser Heizungsgeschichte, nachdem ich jetzt mal ein bisschen umgeklickt habe, bei diesem FS20 etc. handelt es sich natürlich tatsächlich um die von mir eingangs erwähnten Conrad-Devices. Also FS20 ist so einfach mal das Standard-Funk-Thermostat, was halt immer aus dieser Kombination Thermostat und Regler an der Heizung betrifft. Kostet irgendwie 60 Euro die Kombi und dann hast du irgendwie ein Zimmer schon mal gelesen.
Das heißt, man schraubt das Ding an der Heizung ab, so richtig physikalisch dieses, was halt irgendwie mit dem Stift da irgendwie das Ventil steuert.
Das ist ja total simpel.
Und schraubt sich für 60 Euro so ein Ding da ran.
Warte mal, nee, das ist...
Also ein Thermostat ist auch nicht gerade billig, wenn man ihn einfach so kauft. Also ich meine, die sind natürlich immer dran, aber...
Nein, Stellantrieb 1, den gibt's nur einzeln, der kostet 35.
Funkthermostat. Und wie funktioniert das? Also geht das dann über die...
Genau, so ein Funkstellantrieb heißt das jetzt. Und den schraubst du da rein und der kostet irgendwie 35 Euro. Und dann gibt's hier dieses Funkthermostat. Wie sind denn das überhaupt zwei Geräte hier? Das ist das Teil, was du irgendwie hinhängst. Und dann noch irgendwas, was ein... Vielleicht könnte das mal einer erklären.
Und was schraubt man dann auf die Heizung drauf? Also bisher sehe ich nur Schalter und irgendwelche Steckdosen-Dinger.
Geh doch mal in Heizungsregelung und dann FS20-Heizungsregelung.
Ach, bei Konrad, oder wie?
Ja genau, ich rede die ganze Zeit mit Konrad.
Ich bin ja noch beim Google.
Ich mach das mal hier in Chat für euch. So, dann gibt es auch noch diese FHT80BTF.
Ein Sparset für 70 Euro. Und was kann man damit machen? Also toll, ein Bild von vorne, wo ich hier Plastikteile sehen kann. Dann habe ich aber eine Zoom-Funktion, mit der ich Oh, Plastik in groß. Aber wie es von der Seite oder von hinten aussieht?
Ja, wir werden das jetzt nicht vollständig. Aber ich weiß von jemanden, der hat seine ganze Wohnung mit diesem Zeug automatisiert und macht eben genau das, was ich vorhin als wünschenswert erachtet habe. Nämlich, dass man eben wirklich jede Heizung einzeln regelt und für jeden Raum ein eigenes Programm angeben kann. Und das ist natürlich eine durchaus sinnvolle Geschichte.
Schaltenpädchen.
Wann sich das bezahlt macht, ist jetzt mal was anderes. Aber ich finde ja auch den Komfort-Effekt gut. Und natürlich auch dieses, wie soll ich sagen, einfach der Geek-Faktor ist cool. Also ich würde es lieben, in meinem Bett zu liegen und mir den Temperaturverlauf in anderen Räumen anzuschauen.
Das macht mit Strom übrigens auch voll Spaß.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Ja eigentlich, wenn man alles irgendwie so im Griff haben.
Ich will es nur nicht aussausten.
So sieht das aus. Hast du immer noch so einen Funkteil dran?
Hier im Chat ist wohl auch einer, der ordentlich durchverdienst ist. Ja auch so Rollos hoch und runter fahren ist natürlich auch cool. Braucht man natürlich entsprechende Rollos, die das auch können. ZB musst du ja dann so Aufwickeln, Mechaniken.
Oh Gott, da war ich mal in einer Wohnung bei der Werder, und dann ging morgens so was aus dem Bett gefallen.
Da kannst du auch so gut Anwesenheit simulieren, wenn du mal irgendwie ein paar Wochen weg bist. So am besten mit so noch mit Bewegungssensor.
Okay, also es gibt so ein Teil...
Wenn sich irgendjemand den Fenster auf 5 Meter näher hat.
Geht's automatisch auf. Tolle Idee. Und das kann man dann per Fritzbox steuern? Was ist an dem Sparset Spar, außer dass es 10 Euro mehr kostet?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Das kriegen wir jetzt auch nicht mehr raus, weil wir werden jetzt diese Sendung auch zu einem Ende führen, wenn ich das mal kurz so verordnen darf. Wir haben noch eine Sendung und wir hoffen natürlich, dass Huckel dann bei unserer Pré-Weihnachts- und Pré-Kongress-Sendung wieder dabei ist. Stimmt's, Huckel? Du bist dann wieder gesund. Und bis dahin hast du ja auch Blade Runner noch ein paar Mal angeguckt, damit du den auch magst. Ja, immer wieder und immer wieder. Das schau ich mir dann auch mal an. Okay, wollen wir nochmal uns ganz auf die Hörer konzentrieren und Tschüss sagen?
Genau. Ich hab beim nächsten Mal hoffentlich, wollen sie mir zuschicken, als Testgerät, leider nicht geschenkt, so ein Zeppelin Air-Teil. Ja, so eine Basis-Station, wo man per iTunes, AI Airplay mit dem iPhone drauf spielen kann.
Das willst du haben oder?
Nee, das hat der Hersteller angeboten mir netterweise zu schicken.
Zu schenken? Zu Weihnachten?
Nein, zu schenken leider nicht. Muss ich dann wieder zurückschicken. Aber ich darf es mal ausprobieren, kann ja dann berichten. Okay, bin ja immer echt gespannt drauf.
Zeppelin Air, so soll es sein. Max, Dennis, das war's. Wir machen jetzt mal Schluss.
War nur auch drei Stunden.
Genau, das war Mobamex mit Ohne Hucke. ZX natürlich bei uns war. Aber mit vielen Hörern, wir danken fürs fleißige Zuhören. Und ja, wir sehen uns in zwei Wochen wieder.
Wenn es wieder heißt.
Wenn es wieder heißt. Tolles Intro von David. Und ein lustiger Zusammenschnitt von all unseren Wirrnissen.
Wir sind gespannt.
Genau, bei Mismar jetzt sehe ich noch. Erinnert mich mal dran, dann von der TEDx ein bisschen zu erzählen.